all right scumming villainy let's make
some noise for Kevin Smith and Mark
Bernardin fat man beyond
[Applause]
[Music]
hey
ho
welcome to fat man beyond I'm Kevin
Smith I'm Mark Bernardo hey
[Applause]
welcome everybody great to be back sold
out show here it's coming villainy
Cantina in Hollywood on Hollywood
Boulevard put your hands together so the
folks at home know you're real
a very happy Juneteenth to everybody
um
that was almost scary yeah like that
little beep foreign
I have to apologize it wasn't until I
got out of the car that I realized I'm
really not dressed appropriately for
Juneteenth
tell them what you told me in the
alleyway like Colonel Sanders showed up
for juneteen
who got these secret spices
the white hat
[Laughter]
that's true good point good point I did
almost die
um I mean as long as there's no like
Clan Hood in your [__] closet truly
like Don Johnson truly man uh hey what
before we dive into things uh be like
Linus
in the [__] Peanuts Christmas special
where they put a light on him and he has
to explain the meaning of Christmas
and explains you and teens for those
Folks at home who are like do what yeah
uh well uh boys and girls as we gather
around the uh whatever anti-slavery fire
we have here
Juneteenth is a is a celebration of the
day where the residents of Galveston
Texas learned that slavery had been
abolished ooh there's what was that
Galveston chiming in I know over to
Galveston yes live from Galveston now
because you know the Emancipation
Proclamation allegedly freed the slaves
uh but it turns out that nobody told
them and so it took the Union Army to
eventually make its way throughout what
was the country at that point and the
last place they made it to was Galveston
um so it took two years to tell
everybody by the way you don't have to
go to work anymore
um and so that is the reason why we now
celebrate it was June 19 1865. so that's
why it's Juneteenth that's why we
celebrate it is not just a black holiday
it's an American holiday because you
know federal holidays it's a federal
holiday
so uh my my to my white friends you can
now come to the barbecue today
tomorrow's another story but today is
fine
just don't bring potatoes out with
raisins in it
oh hell no
um and thank you for the wakanda forever
deemed appropriate see I'm not [__]
around
um all right um it is also we're just
coming off of Father's Day Happy
Father's Day to you happy Father's Day
to you happy Father's Day to all the
Happy Father's Day to all you
[__] out there what did you do
for Father's day uh I watched movies in
my house without my children
whatever dad wants can you take the
reasons for Father's Day away from me
for a couple of hours
uh but no it was lovely like my my kids
made me breakfast in bed in the morning
[__] tradition then I didn't do
anything all day and watch movies I
watched Time After Time what was the
last time you saw Time After Time the
the uh the Malcolm McDowell David Warner
Jack V probably within the last 10 years
yeah yeah movie really [__] [__]
holds up right it was actually like one
of my first time travel movies that that
explained the concept to me as a kid but
I was like oh that's [__] that's wild
yeah that's how that works and I felt
very on brand for a for a stretch where
I was going to be talking about the
flash
um so I'd watch a good time travel movie
and there's a preview of Mark's opinion
of The Flash everybody
uh can I tell you my favorite the part
of the flash weekend because I watched
it uh let me see I saw it at the
premiere on Monday so a week ago from
today then we had screenings at smog
Castle Cinemas watch with Kev so I
watched it three nights uh in a row so
guess how I feel about it
um but my favorite moment uh outside of
the movie itself movie proper was I
watched it with uh Harley my daughter on
uh Thursday yes it was adorable she was
in Jersey shooting in indie film and so
I picked her up she came down to Smart
castle with Austin uh blockchain
Coltrane from clerks three her boyfriend
and so we're sitting there watching and
I've already seen it at the premiere and
so I'm sitting there watching it with
her and about halfway through the movie
uh she's talking about the two Ezra
Millers on screen
and my actress daughter Whispers to me
do you think they got paid twice
if I had a pause button in the theater I
would have paused it and been like who
raised you man
um yeah no I went to aside from that I
went to the city on uh God was yesterday
Father's Day it was yeah so yesterday I
went I was in New York City I was just
in on the east coast and I was in New
York City we went to see the new
production of uh Sweeney Todd at the
Lunt Fontaine with uh Josh Groban and
Anna Lee Ashford I think her name is
plain Mrs Lovett who is hands down the
best Mrs Lovett I've ever seen I never
saw Angela Lansbury do it in 1979 I was
too young but I've seen five different
mountings of Sweeney Todd which sounds
exactly as filthy as I meant it and she
was [__] incredible it's always a
Darkly humorous show like Gallows humor
but it's actually they turned it into a
flat out comedy and the second half is
still a tragedy but it was absolutely
[__] wonderful man it was packed and
[__] and we had like second row seats I
could see up Josh Groban's nose and
you got those famous people seats no I
just overpaid
anybody could do that you ain't gotta be
famous you just have to [__] be
stupid
um but it was well worth it it was a
really good time and then I got on a
plane this morning uh to come out here I
was gonna go see my mom but I'll go see
her next week uh the boys told me last
week that the show this this show was
sold out I was like oh we could just
stream it and they were like we [__]
sold tickets idiot and it sold out and
so I was like all right here I come so
yeah happy to be here everybody glad to
be in Los Angeles you gave me a reason
to come home and [__] my wife so thank
you very much
that's why I'm wearing this Kingpin like
jacket
a green jacket at the Masters like
here's what I get every time
white is the [__] that shot from my dick
speaking of which we got a sponsor to
read it out
and that sponsor is indeed two ladies
and gentlemen
tonight's episode of fat man beyond is
uh sponsored by a couple people but
first up the good Folks at Bluetooth man
how well does Bluetooth work you can get
a month for free so you might as well
try it man you're gonna like it and so
will your partner
nice you like the delivery I wonder if I
get paid twice for that that was velvety
smoothie it was look at me trust me I'm
clearly a guy who knows what he's
talking about uh this episode is
sponsored by bluetooth Let's Talk About
Sex guys and girls remember the days
when you were always ready to go well
now you can increase your performance
and get that extra confidence in bed
listen up bluetooth.com Bluetooth is a
unique online service that delivers the
same active ingredients as Viagra Cialis
and Levitra yeah fair enough uh but I
know I was gonna say okay with authority
I'm like oh yeah that's the one that
works for me but in chewable tablets and
at a fraction of the cost tell them more
Mark you can take them anytime day or
nights you can plan ahead or be ready
whenever an opportunity
arises nice yeah yeah eat them in a with
a fox eat them in a box
oh no the process is simple sign up at
bluetooth.com consult with one of their
licensed medical providers and once
you're approved you'll receive your
prescription within days the best part
it's all done online so no visits to the
doctor's office no awkward conversations
and no waiting in line at the pharmacy
Bluetooth tablets are made in the USA
and prepared and shipped direct to your
door in a discrete package that now
everybody will know what it is because
we just told them yeah don't wait by the
post for it and [__] your neighbors will
figure it out like he's waiting for his
[__] dick medicine isn't he oh you
got my stiffy pills
uh you could miss you you could sit down
on the best sex of your life kids with
Bluetooth and everywhere are excited to
see the postman just like you said and
truly man because when your package has
arrived your package has arrived
thank you they always say first
impressions are important what about
Lasting Impressions they say there's
nothing sexier than confidence and
Bluetooth can help you give that
confidence where it counts your your
dick yes
Bluetooth wants to help you have better
sex discover your options at
bluechoo.com chew it and do it man and
we've got a special deal for our
listeners uh try Bluetooth free when you
use the promo code Fatman at checkout
just pay five dollar shipping that's
bluetooth.com promo code Fatman to
receive your first month free take that
last line how well did Bluetooth work
you get a month for free [__]
you might as well try it you gonna like
it so will your partner so visit
bluechew.com for more details and
important safety information and we then
Bluetooth for sponsoring us I love you
give it up for the good Folks at Blue
chew
Bluetooth works fast how fast Barry
Allen fast kids
[Applause]
to keep it on topic uh shall we dive in
let's [__] do do it I saw the flash
uh four times now let me throw out a
series of disclaimers Because the
Internet is just [__] having at it
you know I'm not allowed to like things
no and the moment I do people like
you're a [__] idiot I'm like all
right fair enough uh here uh let me say
this uh the issues that people have
brought up time and time again to me
when I say I like a thing they try to
knock you off your [__] high horse of
enjoying a thing one of the reasons
people tell me I should not be liking
this movie is based on the CGI yes that
seems to be something a lot of people
have been attacking online here's my
feeling on CGI people are like don't
look realistic I gave up on realism the
moment I bought a ticket for a movie
about a guy who solves all of his
problems about running [__] fast
I cannot make CGI myself so I never hold
anyone to a higher standard of something
I can't [__] do myself I know a lot
of people think that's some sort of
cop-out but I did direct that so
it makes [__] sense
um
yes some of the CGI looked a little
rubbery or whatever that never once took
me out of the movie that sort of thing
doesn't take me out of the movie at all
you're dealing with things that aren't
really there to begin with so chances
are as long as you can get the
impression across to me I'm never going
to be one of those people I was like
looks fake at the end of the day I don't
give a [__] how real CG kind of works or
it looks it's still
fake in my head I know it's fake like
even if it's like wow that looks
convincing it's like but it's fake
because [__] [__] like that doesn't
happen in the real world so that didn't
pull me out I saw a lot of people being
like the babies didn't look real I was
like see you wanted real looking babies
and Jeopardy falling off buildings you
cruel Fox yeah by the way spoilers yeah
oh my God uh has everybody seen the
Flash
who hasn't seen the Flash
what the [__] is wrong with you now
uh you weren't alone I assure you man I
saw the box it's your fault guys why
this gonna be a flash too it's you and
you guys yeah
um let's see what did I think I look I
uh didn't go to see the flash as much as
I want to see Batman Returns again
co-starring The Flash uh and in that way
I was completely and utterly satisfied I
I it's no secret that I was there for
Michael Keaton Batman Michael Keaton
Batman was like one of those seminal
moments in my movie going life uh June
23rd 1989 one of the happiest days of my
movie going existence uh June 26 1999
one of the happiest days of my real life
that's when my kid was born but June 23
1989 as a movie guard oh my God I mean
[__] you got to remember we weren't
spoiled like everyone is now where they
have a comic book movie comes out every
[__] week they just dropped a trailer
for craving the [__] Hunter for God's
sakes
but well me and Mark were kids they
didn't have that sort of thing we had a
Batman uh two Batman growing up we had
the just the Super Friends Batman and we
had Adam West and so when uh 1989 Tim
Burton's Batman came out my review of
that movie was like oh my God finally
the most realistic Batman that's ever
happened
which now has been a dated comment and
whatnot so between that and three years
later Batman Returns coming out and
admittedly I'm more of a Batman fan than
I am Batman Returns I know a bunch of
people on the internet are now chewing
me a new [__] but I like the first
one just a little bit more
um I I was so excited for this movie the
moment they announced Michael Keaton was
involved I was like that's [__]
fantastic and I base everything on what
I like right so I was like this movie's
gonna make two billion dollars man
because who the [__] doesn't want to see
Michael Keaton put the [__] suit back
on and [__] apparently a lot of people
don't give a [__] about yeah you've got
very specific feelings about June 23rd
1989 very much so yeah others not so
much there's an entire generation that
could give a [__] less about Michael
Keaton being Batman because he was never
that Batman that's the nice thing about
this Batman concept everybody gets one
you know like [__] uh our parents or
like Ralph Garman who's a little older
than made my Hollywood Babylon co-host
his Batman will forever be Adam West uh
my Batman will forever be uh Michael
Keaton uh for some people it's Christian
Bale for others it's it's bat flick
um who's also a bit of mine as well but
like I've I've seen him naked so that
shouldn't count and [__]
um then there are people that are like
Rob Pattinson go [__] figure so
everybody
and don't forget there are largely a
bunch of us who will always think of
Kevin Conroy as the king of all Batman
so
everyone gets
going to get deserved and I really
deserve the Michael Keaton Batman and
loved that Michael Keaton Batman so damn
much was live for the hype when that
movie came out before the movie came out
when they announced Michael Keaton was
cast there was no internet in 1988-89
and still that news broke the [__]
internet because people like ew Mr Mom
Mr Beetlejuice is going to be Batman and
for a year you had to hear that [__] in
the mainstream press and in comic book
stores people bitching about Michael
Keaton I believed in a man because I'm a
big fan of Michael Keaton period as an
actor and he had just come off of clean
and sober where he gave a dramatic
performance most people know him from
his comedy stuff but clean and sober
showed that he could do Darkness he
could do something real so all that
[__] uh hate from Michael Keaton as
Batman went away when the New York Post
published what I think is the first
photo of Michael Keaton in the back
costume wearing in the bat suit next to
the Batmobile and then suddenly that
piece went every everywhere in the world
and everyone started shutting up and you
remember how seriously that release was
treated like Times Square had the bat
Simulator for like one year straight
hanging up people were getting the
[__] bat symbol carved into their
hair and [__] there were people who
didn't [__] know anything about
Batman who jumped on the Batman train
and I'm not one of those like [__] uh
Garage Band fans where it's like I liked
it when it was cool the more the [__]
merrier man the more people liked Batman
in 1989 that was not a bad thing for me
that was a good thing for me I never
liked being alone liking a thing that
you could only explain to a few people
more people jumped on that was great
also more people jump on they can ask
you all sorts of questions that you can
answer for them like during the pandemic
I watched every Marvel movie with my
wife and part of the fun was just
watching the Marvel movie with somebody
who'd never seen him before the other
part was when she was like I don't get
it and I could pause it and be like well
let me tell you the story
I'll tell you the movie Story the comic
book story and the [__] what the
internet says and we do it half an hour
on that and start the movie again and
[__] so I was never one of those people
that was like less I like more I like
when more people come in for example
when we talked about it went across the
spider-verse I I saw that at my movie
theater it's my Gaza cinemas as I was
sitting there watching it it was
Thunderstruck by the notion that here's
a movie that goes so deep not just on
the multiversal concept but on [__]
Spider-Man that like it's mainstream
it's making all this [__] money it's
not making money from just people who
read the comic books your mother your
father your grandparents can appreciate
that [__] movie they have trained us
for the last 10 years the entire
audience the mainstream audience to be
as nerdy as [__] as nerdy as some of us
were back in the day and to quote or to
paraphrase
um Syndrome from [__] The Incredibles
when all of us are nerds then no one
will be and it's nice I I think that's a
cool thing that everyone could get in on
the party the only problem is people get
real tribal about this [__] hardcore
travel nobody could just enjoy a thing
everyone's got to dissect it everyone's
got to throw in their opinion and tell
you and I don't care about people throw
in their opinion it's when people want
to take your opinion away from you or
make it less or tell you you're wrong
for feeling the way you feel about a
[__] piece of entertainment for God's
sakes I love this Flash movie I thought
it was real [__] fun man I had a good
ass time so much so that I watched it
four times here I'm going to admit to
something I probably should admit to as
a filmmaker and maybe [__] Warner
Brothers takes away my right to show the
movie in my movie theater I sat there
and I taped [__] 10 minutes of that
movie
I shot it on my phone the entire Batman
and Russia sequence I was like I'm gonna
jerk off to this and I shot it
from the back of the theater on my phone
nobody was there I said run it and I
just [__] shot it I bootlegged the
[__] out of it I'll never put it online
but I'll be honest with you I have
watched it nine times since then a nice
10 minute clip I watched it on the
[__] plane when I was flying home
person next to me was like is that on
video already
trailers on this show I don't know maybe
because one dude pirate [__] and then
tells everybody it made me so [__]
happy it was like getting the Batman 3
with Michael Keaton that we never
[__] got and no disrespect to Batman
Forever with Val Kilmer which we'll be
talking about in a little while no
disrespect
to the George Clooney Batman no
disrespect to any [__] Batman movie I
would have loved to have seen the third
Michael Keaton Batman movie and we kind
of got it with this
um if you're a DC fan I'm not saying
that you have to be a DC fan to
appreciate this movie but if you've been
a long time long suffering DC fan
it was joyous man I felt it was kind of
like a donoresque dive into DC's
glorious past
um nerdy as [__] you know the Multiverse
is now something that Marvel's done
multiple times and this feels like uh
DC's first live-action step into it if
I'm if I'm not mistaken we've seen them
do it of course in the animated movies
they did the flashpoint as an animated
movie
um and the whole time I was I was
enjoying the [__] out of myself the
opening sequence with the Justice League
or what they gathered of the Justice
League was a good ass time it took me
two viewings to be like holy [__]
they're doing Batman in broad daylight
something that they never [__] do and
then I was like holy [__] he's wearing
the blue and gray suit something that
we've always wanted to [__] see holy
[__] he's talking to the [__] flash
holy [__] spoilers Wonder Woman shows up
holy [__] like there's cohesion here
um now you know I'm not saying like holy
[__] it was better than than anything
Zack Snyder did the exact Snyder laid
the [__] track for us to see these
characters and whatnot and it was a
Bittersweet goodbye to an entire
universe the guy built when you know
Barry's having a conversation with Bruce
Wayne and he's and he nerds out a little
bit where he's like we're friends you
want to like hang out and he goes maybe
not not this time maybe another time and
you know what's about to happen I
thought Ben sold it really [__] well
I've seen Ben as bat [__] again was
joyous
um not only is bat Fleck but as Bruce
Wayne he said in a few interviews he was
like look man I just figured out how to
play this character and that character
and now it's all coming to an end it's
kind of Bittersweet but
he got that bite at the Apple before it
was all done because he said many times
he's never going to go back to Batman
you know
there's a Multiverse so we'll see if
that [__] happens you know I could
see a world where 10 years from now
after he's lived a bunch of other life
and done other things that if someone
because I know Ben loves The Dark Knight
Returns in a big bad way most of us do
but like [__] all through Chasing Amy
he read that on the floor of my condo he
slept on the couch and [__] and he was
always like why can't somebody do this
as a [__] movie and you know when
Zach did bvs he got damn close he got to
wear the outfit and [__] there were
elements of Dark Knight Returns so I
can't imagine if somebody backed up a
money truck 10 years from now and said
to a [__] nearly 60 year old Ben
Affleck do you want to do The Dark
Knight Returns
he might say yeah and that would be
glorious but for right now he had to put
the cowl away and he seems to have had a
good time doing it I know a lot of
people online like went after him as a
smiley Batman because at one point uh he
smiles God forbid and [__] and people
were like what the [__] it wasn't bad I
thought it was a cute little joke with
the lasso of Truth they've done the joke
before but I liked what they did there
if you listen very [__] closely man
because I've watched it four [__]
times when Batman bat Fleck is holding
the the Wonder Woman's uh lasso of Truth
he can't help but first he's like I I
can't say thank you because of my large
ego that I've built you know to deal
with childhood trauma and [__] and then
she says this is the lasso of Truth and
he you hear him say he throws the line
away but I thought it was hysterical he
goes I don't know why I'm trying to get
rid of crime I should get rid of poverty
I have all this money
it's really [__] fun [__] like that I
think what was her name Christina Hodson
Hudson yeah wrote the screenplay she
wrote uh Bumblebee
did she write Bumblebee as well as as uh
the other movie um
um I thought this screenplay was fun I
was shocked at how much humor they went
for in this I'd heard from people
they're like oh it's a funny movie but
they actually did Lean Into The Comedy
of it all I heard a lot of people talk
about like it takes a lot of excuse from
from Back to the Future I mean it flat
out did Back to the Future jokes they
leaned into it so much definitely more
lighthearted than Jeff John's original
Flashpoint uh take on the same subject
matter they kind of you know took one
layer of Flashpoint and then did their
own [__] thing with it
um I thought the Justice League opening
was good time one of the finest comic
book action sequences I've ever seen in
a movie the entire opening sequence him
rescuing all the babies and whatnot was
good [__] time I thought I couldn't
believe they let him get away with like
scalpels [__] racing at Children's
faces acid and [__] he stuck a baby in a
microwave man and the audience [__]
cheered like it was nuts
um so that was lovely and then you know
his whole like why he goes back in time
uh it was
strong enough you know not certainly
they could have gone deeper basically
Iris gives him the idea and he's like oh
my God you're right and then decides to
go [__] it back in time a lot of people
online have attacked the Chrono ball uh
which is what he's running in when he
winds up in the looks like a theater in
the round of of the Multiverse you know
I'm like that's a choice it didn't bum
me out I wasn't like [__] I would
have done it differently I honestly
would never do any of this [__]
differently I don't have that kind of
imagination but in terms of like having
to present a Multiverse it was a choice
they went with it I didn't bump into it
at all
um they showed a lot of people that
looked very CG I think that was because
they weren't going to get everyone live
action so they were like let's establish
a look and go with it which you know for
a person that's grown up reading comic
books it's like there's people make
choices and artists make choices and the
choice they made I didn't bump into I
got what they were going for I was never
[__] visually lost like what the [__]
is going on so I didn't bump into that
at all
um him going back in time to again
spoilers save his mom you know
I I'm not saying you got to be a robot
not to [__] like fall for that
concept but if you got a dead parent man
that [__] works that's why Batman works
so well on me and [__] my dad's dead my
mom was like yeah but you liked Batman
when Dad was alive too I was like I know
I was always wondering what what could
have become of me had you both been
killed in an alleyway
so that you know Jeff Johns created that
aspect to the backstory of Barry Allen
Barry Allen when I was a kid didn't have
like my mom was killed and [__] that was
added years years later but you know
it's it's a concept that [__] works
and they used it well uh in this movie
um him getting knocked into
the his I guess his 18th year once he
goes back and saves his mom by putting a
can of tomatoes in the shopping cart
um he's then gets to see
his mom go through all his years and and
memories that he didn't [__] have and
[__] and then on around his 18th
birthday some dark flash knocks him into
the [__] present time and that's
where most of the movie tends to take
place that's where uh Ezra runs into the
other Ezra and you know if
if you didn't like Ezra Miller having
two of them must have been really
[__] hard for you
because suddenly you got twice the
[__] Ezra Better Than Ezra twice the
Ezra and [__]
um yeah there's lots and lots of that
um the uh and I thought that stuff was
effective uh I laughed I thought there
was a good sense of humor to it
um and then finally they did the thing
that I paid the money to see which was
they went to Wayne Manor and they
[__] brought Michael Keaton back
first is Bruce Wayne as old Haggard
[__] bearded hippie Bruce Wayne who
apparently likes to paint
which I thought was really cute and then
um he has no interest in helping him he
gives a very eloquent explanation of the
Multiverse using spaghetti and then uh
the the berries go into the bat cave and
and they're like well he says like well
if he won't help us we'll use his bat
[__] the other guy's like what which is
a good [__] joke it's a good line
saying batshit
um something I would have done I was
jealous so once they're down in that bad
cave oh my God it all begins even before
they got there they the way they
lovingly recreated the [__] room in
1989's Batman where you know Alexander
Knox is like he was King of the Wicker
people and [__] the way they lovingly
recreated the [__] kitchen where
Alfred tells a story about young Bruce
and [__] like that in 1989's Batman like
it was crazy they would spend such a
short time in these giant [__] sets
like if it were me I would have set the
whole movie in that one [__] room
because I'm like you know how much it
cost to rebuild this [__]
but that's what they do in movies they
[__] spend and boy they spend on this
movie they said 200 million bucks it's
kind of the part of the problem with the
whole thing is like when you spend that
much money then you got to make so much
money back and boy they spent a lot but
this is a movie that's been in
production in one way or another for the
better part of nine to ten years
um with its you know series of problems
that it was fraught with so once uh they
lower the [__] bat wing and once you
see Michael Keaton in the suit and he
does the line which he's been doing in
the trailers and [__] where he's like
yeah I'm Batman
uh we were Off to the Races for me man
Michael Keaton played it exactly like he
played it in 89 and 92 like a a solo act
who doesn't really relate well to others
um the
the the fun call backs to you know the
1989's Batman
um even something as simple as like him
[__] going how much do you weigh like
before he [__] he's trying to launch
like this elevator with the two berries
and uh a very skeletal Supergirl and he
puts an explosive under it and then he's
timing it out or on or measuring it out
on his wrist Gauntlet and [__] and he
grabs this thing which looks like a
Detonator and then he opens it and it's
like measuring tape and he's measuring
to like he's doing Simple [__] math I
thought that was like so sweet man it
echoed back to my Batman exactly where
he was like well I devised this [__] for
a certain weight and I don't know how
much you [__] weigh you know you did
it to Vicki Val in [__] like 30 years
later he was doing it to [__] The
Flash
um putting him uh in in a [__] bat I
mean letting him [__] fight in a way
that he never got to fight before and
yeah like I know that wasn't Michael
Keaton [__] whipping and beating ass
what oh my God but didn't he look like
the fighting version of Michael Keaton
from 1990. all the moves were very
similar just very rapid and much
stronger and he never he kept on always
doing this [__]
totally somebody grabbed him from behind
he backed into a [__] wall and [__]
he used his batarang in an expert
fashion he used the [__]
thing real good I don't know what you
call that obviously uh what's that thing
that thing everything about that
sequence him going to Russia I thought
it was [__] badass and true to
character when they get into the [__]
giant ball that they're holding care uh
Cara zarel and he sees this not Superman
he's like it's not him let's go
and he's willing to [__] abandon her
there and [__] I was like that's my
Batman he don't give a [__]
uh so I loved all that [__] I loved his
sequences as Bruce Wayne where he would
sit there and talk to Barry and talk
about like you know I went I I used I
would put on a cape and fight crime as
if that could bring my parents back like
all that [__] rang so [__] true uh to
my favorite version of Batman so my love
of Michael Keaton Batman definitely
fueled uh my enjoyment of this movie but
that being said if they hadn't gone with
him I still think I would have really
enjoyed the flick I thought it was put
together so well I know a lot of people
online bumped into the third act there
were uh what I feel like were homages to
characters from the past which featured
some actors who weren't with us anymore
I don't know the logistics of that I
cannot imagine that Warner Brothers you
know a publicly traded Corporation
is going to use anyone's likeness
without getting permission from
somebody's estate
can't imagine they'd risk it that being
said if somebody's estate is like have
at it I don't see why it was an insult
some people were just like how insulting
to use the image of Christopher Reeve
theater I was in all four [__] times
when they showed Christopher Reeve
everyone went [__] nuts nobody was
sitting there going boo this is
disrespectful disrespectful everybody
felt oh man there's my Superman or
there's a Superman that I grew up and
then Helen Slater likes flies up next to
him and [__] I was delighted to see Adam
West
um you know George Reeves is not my
Superman I know he has a tragic past in
real life and whatnot
um but I can't imagine they use George
Reeves Superman without getting some
form of permission from his estate you
would have to just because you own a
movie don't mean you own the likeness
rights I know this for a fact because in
Jay and Son Bob Strike Back we had Jay
wearing a shirt that featured the
character of Olaf on the shirt from
clerks and I assume since the studio on
clerks we could use that image and we
couldn't and we got sued and we had to
pay somebody off because of that so if
that was the case with [__] Jay and
Silent Bob Strike Back I can't imagine
Warner Brothers like let's do whatever
the [__] we want they had to get
permission and I didn't bump into those
appearances like I thought it was a nod
to their cinematic past their multimedia
pass I thought it was weird that they
didn't show the guy who played Flash for
nine [__] years man especially when
Ezra showed up on the flash and
especially because I I've heard I don't
know I can't fact check it I didn't
speak to Grant Gustin but I think they
shot a cameo with them and it just
didn't use it for time or whatever the
choice was
um but no I didn't bump into that hard
enough to be like pick up your coach
we're leaving you know just seemed like
an odd choice to show the Jay Garrick
Flash and according to the internet
nobody knows who that Jay Garrick flash
was I thought it was John Wesley ship
but I've heard no in fact I believe you
just told me no you thought it was the
guy who was in The Flash who played Jay
Garrick but turned out to be Zoom
spoilers for [__] six years ago but
he's uh Teddy he's online going it
wasn't me so does anybody know who was
the Jay Garrick Flash
I thought it was John wishlist yeah but
look [__] just like what is it
of John Wesley ship
I mean it could have been pulled from
the show and not a re because John
Wesley's ship gone out Banff man jump in
here real quick
what bam Hey look it's Bam Bam everybody
uh bamf man if I was home of course I'd
be all over uh the comments and [__]
like that you got a laptop in front of
you can you
find out if John Wesley's John Wesley
ship said anything that it was him to me
it looked like him but it's a very quick
pun intended flash of the character so I
don't know if I'm right but we know it
wasn't Teddy because he's out there
saying that it's not him it's it's a
hard thing to Google because you Google
John Wesley's ship Flash and Jay Garrett
and you've you get a thousand results
why don't you add in The Flash movie
[__] and that will help your
search because it's easy to believe that
as much information as possible no you
didn't oh it's still
like [__] burn all the TV it's all
the TV stuff well somebody [__]
smarter than us we'll figure this out
um seeing Adam West even for a second
was cool and to address the [__]
giant spider in the room yes
I was dumb struck and delighted to see
uh [__] Nick cage fighting a giant
spider in the third act man in the third
act
um I a lot of people ask me like did you
what the [__] did you know I I knew
because Russ Burlingame at comicbook.com
had reached out to me a couple weeks
back like when my mom first got sick and
I was in Florida and [__] like that and
um you know I was feeling kind of in the
dumps because at one point they were
like you got to get hospice care for her
which is never a good [__] sign so
Russ was like I could really cheer you
up man he's gone but in order to do that
I have to spoil a piece of The Flash for
you and I don't really care about that
kind of thing so I was like I'd spoil it
and he was like Nick Cage shows up as
Superman and fights a giant spider I was
like get the [__] out of here and I
can't say this for a fact but my mom got
better after hearing that news
uh
shaft of
do with that what you will
[Applause]
um I it was uh I was like delighted when
that moment happened at the premiere I
was sitting next to Jennifer my wife and
I like when it [__] popped up on
screen I turned to Jen and I was like
that's my Superman and Jennifer who has
been with me for 25 years was like yeah
I know
she goes I've heard the [__] story
and [__] I got a second bite of Apple
when I watched it with my kid who I was
like well she don't [__] know so when
that came up on screen I turned her and
I was like that's my Superman she goes
dad everyone knows that you've been
talking about it for years yes for a guy
who told that story over and over again
to see it show up uh was delightful man
as I've told many outlets Rolling Stone
comicbook.com a bunch of people have
asked for a comment on it I'll say the
same thing here I have spent the better
part of 30 years of my career given
shout outs to pop culture and I've now
lived long enough my career has lasted
long enough where pop culture is
starting to shout back and that is
really [__] nice
[Applause]
that being said
I don't feel that was just a shout out
to me that's a shout out to Tim Burton
that's a shout out to Nick Cage a lot of
people been involved in this ill-fated
Superman and a lot of people like can
lay claim to it not the least of which
is John Peters now [__] if all
weekend long everybody's been blowing me
up in my text and on Twitter going like
what the [__] your mind must have been
blown if you think my mind was blown I
wish to God I could have been next to
John Peters when he saw this because I'm
sure that [__] was like I knew
it would have worked
because it looked [__] cool man like
for the 12 15 seconds whatever it was I
was convinced I was like [__] they
should make that movie now man Nick Cage
looked badass and [__] and in a world of
multiverses where we've got like 86
different Batman why can't we have a
[__] Nick Cage Superman movie Man
throw somebody [__] 75 million bucks
and be like do with it what you can
[__] do the Mandy version give it to
Panos cosmatos and do like do the Mandy
version of [__] Superman Lives why
not I guess probably after Flash no
chance yeah
um when we get into the third Act
one thing I thought was uh kind of
effective they did a bad job at hiding
that uh young Barry would eventually be
the villain that was the one thing I
thought was strange the whole movie is
yes Zod is there but really the movie
doesn't have a villain so much you know
Zod is a threat but it's not like
[__] Barry's fighting grief seems to
be the big enemy that's the driving
factor that sends it back in time and
whatnot
um finally in the third act other than
Zod they give us the True Villain the
Barry that young Berry is the one that
knocks old Barry or older Barry uh into
into 10 years ago where we spend most of
the story and whatnot and I like that I
thought it was kind of dope the way he
was just like young Barry was like no he
wouldn't accept the deaths he was like
again it's like show is a real video
game mentality man entire generation
raised on like we'll just hit restart
and [__] go which is something you
can't do in the real world and I thought
it was kind of Bittersweet that they
went with that in the movie as well
where older Barry at one point goes this
world eyes today like no matter what we
do and [__] younger Barry wouldn't
accept it and is apparently spent
[__] time immemorial trying to go
back and [__] write it and write it
and write it and couldn't do it the
entire time I thought that was kind of
dope watching uh I thought Supergirl was
wonderful but my God like I was shocked
when they spoilers deep spoilers killed
her off and then killed her off and then
kept [__] killing her off and [__] I
was like there goes that franchise
um
but uh I kind of got what they were
going for man and then uh the the really
Bittersweet uh piece was watching my
Batman die came back and then I had to
watch him die twice my only complaint is
I wish they would have let him die a
third time because I'll watch Michael
Keaton go out heroically as many times
as they were if they wanted to do two
hours of Michael Keaton Batman dying and
saying something Bittersweet each time I
would have been there for it and [__] I
thought it was really a wonderful you
can make that cut for yourself thanks to
your it's on my [__] phone just
[__] Loop it I didn't I didn't shoot
that part I shot him kicking ass I think
you've got opportunity I will I'm gonna
go back and shoot the whole thing and
cut my version of the movie I'm Barry
Allen now I'm gonna write the wrongs of
the past
um it was uh you know watching him fly
to batwing into the [__] plane where
he couldn't get out and [__] and he kind
of flies into it in the Kamikaze style
was it was you know like yeah that seems
like a Batman thing to do I thought it
was badass as [__] though where he's
fighting the space giant he just keeps
putting bombs on him and finally his
[__] head blows up and that's when
he's [__] you know falls to the
ground and [__] and then uh the flash is
you know holding them and talking to him
and he's like you know he says I I can't
bring you back can you can I and he's
like you already did kid like oh come on
man you gotta be a [__] robot not to
be touched by that [__]
[__]
[__] I loved it I loved that moment and
stuff
um when Barry has to face the
inevitability of like all of this was my
fault by a [__] his Tony Stark moment
that he created all this by making a
choice uh and and sticking a can of
tomatoes in a cart I like that scene I
thought it was strong when he went back
and saw his mom somebody asked me in one
of the Q and A's I did at smog castle
like do you think his mom knew it was
him and I was like I don't think that's
what they were playing for in the movie
I said but it'd be hard not to know it
said he takes she takes his [__]
glasses off at one point looks exactly
like her son but you know she just was
like being kind to a stranger and [__]
like that I thought that scene was
effective you know made me glass up and
then um you know him
young Barry
kind of sacrificing himself which is
what kills old old Barry made sense
um and then Barry running back through
time fixing things coming back to a
present where it's not you know the PS
to the whole [__] movie is the joke
button is uh a Batman gets out of the
car and uh Ernie smog Castle keeper
Ernie O'Donnell is my partner in smog
Castle
along with Ashley and Jeff Swan they
went to see it at cinemacon where I was
supposed to go with them but that's when
my mom got sick and stuff so I couldn't
go
Ernie said that was the Moment the movie
Ended as soon as the door opened her
foot came out of the car they cut it and
he was like I think they were trying to
surprise us to keep the surprise hidden
I think there's a world where they
hadn't shot that until like [__] two
weeks ago like it feels like they were
like it could be anybody and I'm sure
they were asking Christian Bale for like
months and months hoping that he'd break
down and he was like no so they're like
all right let's pivot let's do another
Batman and they just grab George Clooney
which was kind of fun and funny and and
uh and cute and stuff like that so I
watched the movie four [__] times
enjoyed it four [__] times
um
yes
uh visual reference
um and I'll watch it again a couple more
times
um I you know I'm a comic book movie fan
I'm not Discerning kids if you ever want
to hear an intelligent take on this [__]
or [__] you know critical take on
this [__] I I hope by now you understand
that it's never going to come for me
it will generally come from the man to
my left
me it'll never be me oh I I like it too
much I grew up in an era without all
this [__] and to have a movie like this
you know and then of course online a
bunch of people are like well Ezra's
problematic and and you know I I thought
I was gonna have to be asked that
question when I went to the premiere but
Warner Brothers made it a red carpet
where it was just photos only and nobody
with a microphone and [__] but if
somebody had asked me I would have said
look I went crazy recently and I went to
a mental health facility and not once
did I ever see Ezra Miller comment on it
so I'm not going to comment on Ezra
Miller's mental health issues and
whatnot uh you know there are people
that make these movies and some of them
aren't like golden shining Paragons of
virtue and whatnot so I kind of left
that at the door and and you know I'm
sorry if that makes me a bad person and
stuff but I went in to watch the movie
and I watched the movie many many times
um I enjoyed it man I I I'm not gonna
raise something up or lower something to
raise raise something up but I enjoyed
it more than some comic book movies I've
seen more recently
um you know I I hoped that it would do a
bunch of [__] money I don't have skin
in the game I'm not one of those people
that's like I root for a movie to make
money or even worse I root for a movie
not to make money there are a bunch of
people online who are like rooting for
this movie to fail actively like I hope
it flops and [__] I was hoping that it
did better than it did or at least great
because Michael uzlin's kid said that
Michael uzlin Michael oozland Benjamin
melnicker two guys whose names have been
on every Batman movie and an animated
film uh because Michael oozling went and
got the rights from Warner Brothers
years and years ago I'm sure most people
have seen him on Batman extras and
whatnot wonderful guy lives in Jersey
but I saw his kid at the premiere and
his kid was just like I said where's
your dad he goes he's home watching the
grosses and I said why and he goes
because if this movie does as well as
the Batman and the Batman Matt Reeves
the Batman opened at 130 million dollars
so he goes if this movie opens as well
as the Batman one of the next Batman
movies they're going to make is Batman
Beyond with Michael Keaton
so I was like oh my God now I hope the
movie makes a lot of money based on last
weekend we're never going to see that
Batman Beyond movie
with Michael Keaton so it's kind of a
damn shame now you know don't don't weep
for Andy machete they've announced that
he's going to make the next Batman movie
which is the Brave and the Bold so
clearly you know they think that he's a
talent I think he is too I thought the
movie was enjoyable as [__]
um so I'm I'm I was there for the flash
Man four [__] times and I'll be there
a couple more times as well uh it was a
good time
here we go
oh
oh man I love a Bloodsport you guys this
is great
take her down Mark take her down here
here's what I will say okay I love
Michael Keaton I thought he was great I
loved Sasha Kelly okay I'm not sure you
pronounced your last name who played
Supergirl she's amazing like every scene
she's in she holds it down
um
I once you get to the Michael Keaton
shows up and it becomes a superhero
movie I'm like all right this is fun
enough I love the fact that Michael
Shannon's like what are we doing great
is that again fine I don't really want
to be here but you're paying me so I'll
[__] put this [__] on again and then
I'm gonna [__] on it every chance I get
he did he did kind of talk about it
where he was like well look in Man of
Steel I got to dive into a character
he's like here they told me where to
stand and and told me what to say and he
said it was more like being an action
figure something he was like being
played with as an action figure which I
kind of get Michael Shannon is a legit
[__] actor one of the greatest actors
of his generation and stuff and this
movie while it was fun to see him in the
suit didn't really allow him to act as
much as he you know is as gifted to
Deuce indeed
um so much of this movie rides on two
things it rides on your being gobsmacked
by slow motion supposing to be fast
motion
and twice the Ezra Miller you thought
you were going to get
I don't have a ton of patience for
either only because I've seen the former
quite a bit and I am not as Enchanted by
Andrew Miller as some people might be
um for various reasons and it seems the
audience is not that enchanted with them
either
um
he just got that
but here here was my problem with it
like too much of the movie is Back to
the Future with way too much of the
shittiest McFly namely it's back to the
future too
like that's [__] low man is that it's
the hapless oh gosh Dad I'm home what
are we on for dinner oh pizza man I
don't want it
it's that for an hour and that's a bit
too much of that for me
um and and while I'm here for a guy who
just wants to to see his mom again
I didn't understand how his mom being
alive a lovely white lady from suburbs
suddenly means that Superman is dead
like I couldn't connect those dots not
only the Superman is dead but he was
dead before his mother would have been
killed
right like that's the chronology like by
the time he saves his mom he is eight
right he's a younger person than [__]
Superman is yeah or 12 however old he's
supposed to be
Clark Kent would have already landed on
Earth
oh my God you're right and so and
no but then you can
oh it's the spaghetti excuse It's always
what you're what you're missing at home
kids front camera please what you're
missing at home you can be Latino and
white you know
well okay welcome Spain would you like
to talk to Spain they're all white
people in Spain
FYI they're European there's a whole
interview hey happy Juneteenth you guys
that doesn't know what's going on anyway
the audience argument was the spaghetti
argument is what negates what Mark just
said yeah except again
it's one quote unquote white lady in the
suburbs
who is somehow involved with her death
with Interstellar events like that is
not a butterfly effect that I can
[__] buy buy spaghetti
so
she was Spanish
excellent thank you
foreign
look I'll buy that I'll take that
so like I just once once the movie
stopped being about Barry and his mom
because it does stop being barbarian's
Mom it becomes oh Zod is going to
destroy the planet
then I'm less interested in it because I
was here for the story of a kid who
wants to have his mom back
a kid who Maybe
his mom which he doesn't seem at all
concerned with at all
like should I stop the guy who's
murdering my mom nah I'm about this
Tomato life yo so I gotta put this
[__] can on I gotta make sure she's
got it in the card so she still dies but
maybe a little later though but I could
stop it from ever happening nah
should I find out who it is
and I didn't bump into that but you're
absolutely right like like because
here's why here's why I know logically
they didn't touch it because Andy
machete said in the sequel it was all
going to be the reverse flash so that's
why they didn't address it in this movie
but what did you say out in the in the
alleyway beforehand I don't remember it
was uh I said that to Mark I was like
well Andy machete said that that's what
they were going to do in the sequel
don't set the table for tomorrow when
you're cooking a meal today yeah like
you may never get to tomorrow so make
the movie that answers these questions
like at the very least tell me why he
doesn't care
because he doesn't at all and his magic
solution for this is I'm gonna put these
[__] cans up on the top shelf just so
my dad can suddenly like his face can be
on this on the screen I can spring it
from jail as opposed to hey coppers
here's the guy who killed my mom
I guess that would have made a lot more
sense but that's okay we're all about
restocking shelves so
um so how did they get that far without
somebody pointing that out
I mean apparently there's 98 versions of
this movie and maybe it had been
something that had been there before and
they went a different way and all these
movies have these sort of vestigial
limbs that maybe get sutured and maybe
don't maybe that was one of them I'm not
sure but it just felt as if you know a
dude who works in like literally the
police [__] crime investigative unit
is never like I wonder who that was
who like shank my mom
I never thought of that you know and so
like that's when it decides it needs to
have Supergirl when it decides it needs
to have I don't even mind Batman because
Batman's a [__] detective should be
the guy to say Hey Barry who killed your
mom
maybe we should do that wouldn't that be
great if we figure out who that is but
they needed to have an end of the world
they needed to have some giant pulse
you're saying Batman should have asked
that question yeah
don't attack Michael Keaton Batman
[Applause]
he's [__] infallible he's like the
pope he's the Pope
I'm not sure how infallible the pope is
um like listen I I didn't hate this
movie at all I put that on a poster I
mean that that is my standard like I
didn't hate this movie
two thumbs kind of to the side
[Laughter]
meh says Mark Bernard
it's a little mid
um but it just it emotionally it didn't
really hold together because it kept
taking its Eye Off the Ball which is
here's a guy just wants to save his mom
and when they engage with that it's it's
actually very touching and that's seen
at the very end where he gets the last
moment with his mom and gifts to hugger
like it's adorable and wonderful and it
rolls a tear because of course it does
but I just
I didn't care about Zod you know I
didn't I didn't care about that whole
thing I didn't care about living and
apparently that [__] ship the world
engine is to the DC Universe what the
blip was to Marvel which is like guys I
kind of had about enough of this is
there another story we can tell that is
not about this and it seems as if that
answer is not quite
um or at least not yet I'm hoping that
James gone in his vast array of movies
that he wants to make is is less
concerned with a world engine and Zod
than this movie was
um and I always have troubles with a
movie where it wants to be static the
goal of this movie is to return to the
status quo
which is actually kind of it's very much
Wizard of Oz like that and as much as
like Dorothy starts in a place goes on a
magical adventure and ends in the same
[__] place and this movie was the
same thing like somebody asked me at the
Q a at smodcast over the weekend like
how does this affect the DC Universe
going forward I was like not really at
all it doesn't and how does it affect
Barry Allen going forward not much do
you think he's now trapped in a pocket
Universe though
sure the spaghetti verse
where where everything is possible in
this little bowl I was like I can have
all these Batman okay and why are there
different Batman and not different
flashes
like it's always the weird Multiverse
thing where it's like listen you guys we
want to have like a bunch of different
Spider-Man but also we went to
multiverses and it's the same doctor
strange and all these multiverses so why
is that how why are these rules so odd
and different like there's 19 Batman but
there's never the same Batman
yeah hey Bam fans here give it up man
he'll tell us what to do
just because we've been lucky to have 19
different Batman that we can put in a
movie but Benedict Cumberbatch is the
only doctor strange it's like a real
world problem
100 cast a bunch of pale British dudes
to also be Doctor Strange
like that's cheap
like BBC's got him on speed dial so so
like I don't know and I kept on
wondering why there's no Linda Carter
yeah you know like if you're gonna show
me the parade of various people in
various universes
[__] Linda Carter yo that's true you
know where's Michelle Pfeiffer like
where's where's like that Michael Keaton
Batman did not have a story of his own
his story is entirely Barry's story
except for when he says to lose my
parents because his parents Gotta Die I
guess
and like but what does he want what's
his regret and you [__] got Michelle
Pfeiffer who's still alive and still
acting and still hot as [__] like give
me a scene with Selena Kyle and Bruce
Wayne where he regrets [__] that up
because he was an [__]
like do the thing do the job guys
so listen hey if you love this movie I'm
so glad you love this movie If you like
this movie hooray for you
um I made 55 million dollars this
opening weekend which is worse than
Black Adam yeah that was really bad they
were they were original estimates a
month uh two months ago it was going to
open 140 million then they readjusted
last month or when it went up on
tracking to say like it's not going to
do that much you know we're hoping to
get to 90 or something then that number
kept coming down even on Sunday night
they were saying or Saturday and Sunday
they were projecting
um 60
with another 10 on Juneteenth correct
which a lot of people were like why do
you suddenly think it's going to make 10
million on Juneteenth it's not because
of all the black people in the movie
[Applause]
one
kind of like IRS West is barely a
character in this movie I even forgot
she was in the movie and somebody was
like no no all right freaking Kirsty
Clemons is there I was like oh that's
right
um so he was never making like 10
million dollars no and so now it's as of
today they talked about like what did it
do 50. it did 55 for the three days and
then I think another six or 61. so
that's definitely less than Black Adam
definitely less than
um
well Black Adam was their bar because
they were going like it's got to do
better than Black Adam because Black
Adam was considered a tank yeah and so
if it doesn't then my God
what is this considered I haven't seen
anyone call it a flat out flop but they
are saying it's a huge disappointment it
is and you know
nobody's really sure why you know
there's a lot of Monday morning
quarterbacking there's a lot of second
guessing there's a lot of you know was
it the fact that you didn't have a star
who was going to do press
or even if you had a star that could do
press which like they were wise not to
uh to do that
um because of the writer's Guild strike
there were no late night shows either
there's no late night shows and like
nobody knows how much magazine covers or
online stories put butts in seats it's
unclear it's unclear how much the
audience just didn't want to [__] with
Ezra Miller
um that that story is a big part of it
that story his story their stories
excuse me I have to remember I'm a 51
year old person who's still getting used
to things yeah their stories have been
public and have been proliferating
through the internet for a good long
while people know who they are they know
what they did and so whether those
things get exonerated whether he's
indemnified whether he's whatever those
things whether they are getting the help
that they need in going through
treatment and will emerge a different
person and a better person all of that
is on the table but the public
perception is maybe not this guy slash
person
still getting there
um
and so I don't know those are all open
questions
um it is entirely possible that the 50
million dollars they hoped they were
going to make extra on top of this for
the flash could have been spent
reshooting the flash with a different
person
um
I'm just saying it was always there you
guys it was always an option you had we
found out why they didn't because they'd
shot not just one movie with Ezra Miller
but two Ezra Miller movies essentially
because Ezra played two parts got paid
twice even yeah he got paid twice
according to my kid
um
so listen that's that if again if you
dug The Flash I'm happy for you I'm
always happy if you dig a movie it
didn't work for me on a couple of
different levels some of which were just
emotional some of which were the plot
didn't quite crank out for me the way I
hoped it would
um Nostalgia only ever goes but so far
um not for me man
Nostalgia that's all you need you don't
even need a plot or good acting
or good CG if it's just a pure [__]
shot of nostalgia to my heart man I'm
like oh this is the best
but again I'm not known for my
Discerning taste and [__] I did make
yoga hosers
can I have this [__] bamf hey Batman
welcome back so there's uh rolling back
to who played the Jay Garrett flash yes
who answers there are a lot of people
think it's Teddy Sears Teddy spiders
um and so Teddy Sears has said it's not
Teddy's here it is not there's a lot of
outlets that are saying it is but it is
not but Teddy Sears has said it's not
yet he's here so the anything
so the intern so the the
consensus on the internet and will
Wilkins sent this as well uh who's
watching at home dilfman is that uh
that it's a generic CG representation of
the comic book character that there's no
actual actor nobody playing it yeah
welcome to the Future actors this is
what it's going to be for you guys
flat gbt
um so what did you think uh Banff man
um I uh
lost my mom a handful of years ago and
so a guy doing whatever it takes
including ruining all the spaghetti
verses to spend a couple extra minutes
with his mom just worked for me and I
didn't need anything else motivating and
then Michael Keaton showed up and I was
just in the bag
for the rest of the movie it didn't
matter
I was there I thought that uh
the motivation for Barry to ruin the
Multiverse was much better than the mo
than the reasons for Doctor Strange to
ruin the Multiverse in two movies
wow
it's like Peter Parker just wants to go
to college so let's screw everything up
like at least I get Barry going after
his mom you got balls dude the
internet's gonna come for you hard
they love that they love seeing all them
Spiderman like I you know I I I I no
disrespect whatsoever but like
when Toby Maguire showed up and no way
home I wasn't I wasn't crying and [__]
because I I didn't have an emotional
attachment to Toby Maguire Spider-Man
like I do to Michael Keaton as Batman
that being said I understand people's
emotional attachment to Tobey Maguire as
Spider-Man like [__] the theater I
saw it and people were like
like Christ returned to Jerusalem and
[__] so I get it
um
but you know for for me that's how I
felt about seeing Michael Keaton return
it was like holy [__] he's here I can't
believe it and stuff so internet being
what it is the internet [__]
internet's all day long for you to
[__] come at Toby Maguire in any way
shape or form all I'm saying is like you
should have somebody accompany you to
your car when you leave here tonight
I love Toby McGuire Spider-Man that's my
Spider-Man
I just
don't quite understand
why Dr Strange risked everything to get
Zendaya into Harvard
I know exactly why
[__] Kevin feige wanted it that way
which we saw on She-Hulk they explained
it yeah exactly exactly just f-e-i-g-e
um yeah so that's it man
The Flash
um
let me tell you one of the things
about that movie was uh watching
like you know we've seen Michael Keaton
Batman stand next to Catwoman we've seen
Michael Keaton Batman stand next to the
Joker stand next to penguin so we've
seen him amongst comic book villains
it's the first time he ever got to see
him standing next to a comic book hero
so seeing him in the same frame with the
Flash and Supergirl just like did
something for me it reminded me of the
TV Guide cover from when I was a kid
where they put up the image of Michael
Keaton Batman next to the image of
Christopher Reeve next to the image of
John Wesley's ship as The Flash and that
was like as close as you were ever gonna
get to seeing Michael Keaton Batman
standing next to another hero and [__]
so seeing them like go down the hallway
together when they were like leaving
Russia and and the one guy comes in and
[__] Michael Keane Batman goes like
this he doesn't Flinch and it goes like
that
it was just dope man watching them
[__] fight side by side was really
cool
um I for some reason that that was
something I was not expecting that would
please me I would have been content to
just watch a one-man show of Michael
Keaton Batman but seeing him stand next
to the Flash in costume his you know
[__] dark costume versus the Flash's
very bright costume just was a happy
place for me a few times that it
happened in the movie
um yeah
watching him help the flesh try to
become the Flash
with a bat kite
was my happy place
I don't know who made the choice that he
should wear so many knicker chips though
man
very thirst and howl the foreign
they're like how do you dress a
billionaire oh I know a neckerchief
I guess that seems a lot like back to
the feet like you were talking back that
is Back to the Future isn't it they just
made put little Back to the Future in
the middle to the Future yeah that nice
nice let's see what you did there
a dad joke the day after Father's Day
well done
[Applause]
um that's my secret cap I'm always Dad
joking
um speaking of dad jokes we have another
sponsor kids we do indeed and who is it
this time uh this time it is oh [__]
yeah it is uh yes well guessed boy you
watched this show don't you
that's right kids uh before we dive into
uh Batman Forever colon the Schumacher
cut uh we're gonna talk about cutting
ball hair
trimming huevos you guys uh our our uh
next sponsor and our last sponsor
evening uh are the good Folks at
manscape give it up for the good Folks
at manscape ladies and gentlemen
or for the purposes of this show Batman
escaped man if you haven't heard already
nice it's smooth sack summer kids
did you hear that
I was just talking to my wife about it
today uh when you're playing in the
Summer sun make sure you've escaped from
pubes to bum that's right this is the
summer to keep your balls cool while
still looking hot with manscape the
leaders in below the waist grooming are
making sure we all have a ball this
summer by giving our pants Partners
everything they need to stay fresh dive
head first into smooth sack summer My
Friends by going to manscape.com for 20
off and free shipping with our code
which is of course fatman20 take it away
mark can we just take a moment to to
admire the punish of that first
paragraph yeah like there's a lot of
work in there and I don't want them to
think that we don't appreciate uh how
much rhyming was done there uh thanks
manscape yeah well done man whoever
writes this [__] hats off uh the
manscape performance package 4.0 has
everything you need to prepare that
summer bod they have built the Ultimate
Grooming bundle for your summer grooming
I'm not saying that
I think it's grooming twice
we gotta criticize this as well this
ain't the flash you're gonna write this
[__] George uh the lawnmower 4.0 trimmer
features a Cutting Edge ceramic blade to
reduce grooming accidents thanks to an
advanced skin safe technology that's the
last place you want a grooming accident
right there the lawnmower 4.0 has a 7
000 RPM Motor that's more RPMs than your
car it's more than my moped that I drove
in the 80s right next to your balls a
new multi-function on off switch can
engage a travel lock and gives you the
ability to turn on the 4000k LED
spotlight on and off we needed single
Batman to shave his balls did he mention
that the trimmer is waterproof too
waterproof lake or shower this razor
will devour even the strongest pubes who
is shaving their bush in the lake
[__] Jason Voorhees
now that you have the perfect haircut
use manscapes Liquid formulations to
keep that freshness even at the hottest
summer barbecues man most importantly
use the crop preserver ball deodorant to
stay cool in the heat with a soothing
aloe vera formula it's the best in the
business for below the waist freshness
and this clear drying formula will keep
looking good while smelling good as well
manscape even threw in two free gifts to
their performance package 4.0 the
manscape boxers and the shed travel bag
wearing sandals with some nasty ass
toenails during the summer months take a
look at the shears 2.0 a luxury nail
grooming kit which includes stainless
steel nail cutters tweezers and grooming
scissors with the performance package
your balls will be ready to impress but
make sure you cover the rest with shears
2.0 get 20 off plus free shipping with
the code Fatman 20 at manscape.com go do
it we'll wait
yeah
well we gotta go move on uh that's 20
off plus free shipping with the code
Fatman 20 at manscape.com it's smooth
sex summer boys get on board or get left
behind and we thank the good Folks at
manscape for sponsoring fat man beyond
give it up for them kids
uh all right so I have not seen the
Schumacher cut yet
um so tell me about it let me tell you
about the secret Origins
so uh we were at smog Castle
uh Cinemas I don't know if I ever
mentioned this but I own a movie theater
um where is it in New Jersey Atlantic
Highlands New Jersey
um so we were doing uh before all the
screenings that I attend were the
functions that I'm involved in uh we do
auctions of like [__] science stuff
of rare props of like costume pieces
just whatever I've got uh to augment the
the what we pull in at the theater
because film exhibition is a dying
[__] medium right now we bought a
movie theater at the worst [__] time
to buy a movie theater so in order to
keep the lights on pay the staff and
[__] like that uh we tend to do these
auctions so
what was I auctioning
it was the Jersey Girl test scores so I
had a packet of test scores from Jersey
girl for like the first three or four
screenings or something like that and
you know I held on to these dogs I'm a
pack rat a whole I'm like I'm a hoarder
they could put me on that show and I
hold on to [__] forever and so that
night I was like oh somebody will
[__] buy this and stuff so some of
them went for like real money man
somebody bought one of them for like 250
bucks which was awesome because it was
like that brought my pain away from me
because these test scores they were not
[__] positive and [__] but one of
them was the test the first test that
changed the [__] movie that made us
take out all the Jennifer Lopez and
stuff like that so there were historical
documents man not so much that Nick Cage
would go hunting for them one day and
[__] but definitely for like a movie
buff so my man what is your name again
so Joe Black
is there at the screening Joe Black
lives you live out here correct Joe
lives out here but he went back East for
other things or just to see Jersey Girl
just to see that I know [__] give it
up for me travel the [__] world
[Applause]
like Michael Shannon he crossed an ocean
of stars to [__] get to kill this
infant yes to get to smodcast to watch
the Jersey Girl snipe the Snyder cup we
call the longest cut of Jersey girl ever
was so we're doing the auction auction
off the test scores and during the
auctions it becomes an auction sometimes
people bid against each other it gets
real fun and [__] so Joe at one point
was bidding and he bit a number I'm just
going to say like a hundred bucks but
then he threw in he goes a hundred
dollars
and the Schumacher cut of Batman Forever
and I was like what the [__]
are you serious and he was like getting
chauffeur so a lot of [__] what is it 69
bucks it was so wow perfect joke the
sexiest number there was and a
Schumacher cut a Batman Forever so a lot
of people online for the last two weeks
since we spoke about it were last month
when we spoke about on the last streamed
version of fat man beyond they're like
Kevin Smith's got the [__] cut he has
inside connections and [__] Joe has
inside connections I he just got a copy
and he was [__] kind enough to throw
it in and so I was like bam I'll [__]
take that all day long so I got the cut
from Joe Joe got it from someplace else
and we'll leave that there you're not on
camera so you're all [__] good and
[__] you don't care Joe's like [__]
show my face come on up show me your
[__] face real quick this is our hero
right here kids give it up for Meet Joe
Black right there
yeah go behind JC's
gives dodging every camera
um give a little do the bamf man Cam and
let's get a little background on this
bamf uh this is Joe Black everybody and
to the home audience
everybody Meet Joe Black Joe Black
everybody for the folks who are like oh
my God [__] Kevin Smith will save us
on the Schumacher cut it's not Kevin
Smith Joe did it what is your background
history with this uh I got to see a
special screening of it somewhere and uh
I acquired it afterward I actually tried
to take footage from the 4K release of
it and like put that over because a lot
of it's still in there but yeah yeah
after like doing that for like a month I
got tired now it's like it's fine it is
it's utterly watchable that's the first
thing I'll say is like for a you know a
[__] bootleg cut on a thumb drive and
[__] it looks like it was taken off the
Avid in 1995 it's dated because the
movie goes back that far but like it
looks like an
it's utterly watchable it's is it
pristine like no it doesn't look like
the flash looked like this weekend but
can you especially if you've seen this
movie a bunch and I've seen Batman
Forever many times
um is it utterly watchable absolutely
now I thought it was a clean cut what
was interesting about it
um to me aside from like all the added
material was it was at a point in the
movie's life where they had the Batman
march by Elliot goldenthal which they've
reused a couple times but the rest of it
was temp scored with Tim with Danny
elfman's Batman and Batman return score
as well as other movies so when you're
like Interview with the Vampire music
there was Interview with a Vampire is
that what it was from because I heard a
lot of that [__] I was like sounds
familiar when you're cutting a movie
together you obviously the last thing
you get to put onto a movie is the score
right so if you're dealing with
characters that have been in a movie
prior to that you could use the previous
score for motherboard for example when I
was cutting together Jay and Silent Bob
reboot I was using uh Jim Venable score
from Jay and Silent Bob Strike Back and
then he came in and created the new
score once the movie was cut so at this
stage in the movie's life
um before they start getting in there
and hacking [__] out
how long was this cut uh it's not that
much longer it's like two and a half
it's like two hours and 30. yeah I saw
people on the internet going it's a
three-hour cut of the movie I'm like not
really but there was definitely extra
stuff in it but it was at a point in
this movie's life where they must have
shown it they must have tested it either
showed it to movie execs back in because
it was 95 this [__] came out or test
screened it and then decided right then
and there we're gonna start bringing it
in which I don't think it was conspiracy
I've read a lot of people online talking
about how could they keep this movie
down the version I saw and you back me
up feels like it was just cut for
commercial considerations that's it yeah
I mean it he doesn't Batman in this for
the first like 15 minutes like the whole
bit with like the Riddler like meeting
him you know that's how the movie starts
after a John Favreau Cameo that's right
John favreau's in it which I don't know
if he was in the theatrical code
or uh no as yeah as an interesting John
Favreau from swingers he plays Bruce's
[__] he just works for him he's like
trying to stop this guy or something
like that he's not happy Hogan no but
it's crazy though he he has lines and
[__] and and you're like what the [__]
and then you start wondering like wait
did I miss him in the other one
um but it's in a scene in uh at Wayne
Tech or in his office in Bruce Wayne's
office where his assistant is there and
somebody else is there and they're
coming at Bruce Wayne with a bunch of
issues as Joe points out
he does not Batman for the first 15
minutes of the movie so one of the first
things they do is take you to Arkham and
show you Harvey Dent's Origins including
that piece of him in the courtroom where
he leaps over and [__] like that and
they talk about him being there and they
show the doctor going down the hallway
then they get to the cell
and I guess it's his guard has been
killed and he's hanging up and [__] like
that yeah it's a weird spring-loaded
contraption that I don't understand but
it somehow explains that Harvey escaped
through a skylight and there's like some
kind of like the bat Must Die the bat
Must Die is written on the wall and
stuff so definitely darker again you got
to remember Batman Returns was so dark
that like [__] McDonald's is like
we're not making happy meals with you
guys anymore
so the whole idea of Batman Forever was
like let's lighten this [__] up and so
it feels like most of this [__] was cut
in deference to that where they're like
look it's called Batman Forever let's
not make it forever until he gets in the
movie and so they cut it you know to
what we all saw which was like it opens
there's a title and [__] you know
Batman is two faces robbing the bank and
[__] and Batman is in there as quickly
as possible in this version you got a
two-face not origin but like all this
backstory that leads to his escape and
then you also meet
uh Edward nigma and spend time with him
and that's the stuff that plays later in
the movie was there much extra added
there no right no no no no no I mean
there's a couple little things like you
see a little more of uh nigma working on
Closer Closer Closer working on his
machine before he like meets him but no
not really do they explain how Eddie um
how Harvey Dent was a black guy once no
no is that part of the secret origin I
was waiting for that I was like when do
they get into the Juneteenth of this
[__]
there's not plaque anymore
their explanation is a lame Batman
that's what they say in the news they
did that in the comics though I
understand yeah so in the Batman uh 1989
books that they're doing for DC I think
it's
it's uh Billy D Williams yeah
and there's a cartoon movie right where
where they had the ability in Lego
Batman one of the Lego Batman movies
Billy D Williams was the voice of
Two-Face if I remember correctly but no
they don't touch on that at all
um you know I don't think they've added
much new of
of uh Tommy Lee Jones no he got screwed
over the most so if you ask me because
the big thing that you notice by saying
yes to the movie or no well no
cut is that like you know you talked
about like who you know who someone's
Batman is you know what I mean uh
Michael Keaton's Batman's first movie I
ever saw in a theater so he's my Batman
even though you know I was age
appropriate for Batman Forever for Val
Kilmer right who I I think my people my
age reject him as their Batman in a
weird way but Tommy Lee Jones got a lot
of flack for just being like a uh like
over-the-top goofy whatever felt like he
was trying to do Jack Nicholson's broker
right but when you watch this cut you
realize they dubbed half of his [__] in
the movie because like it's the same
footage it's the same take but the
inflection is different in almost every
line he has like the like one that I can
really think of off the top of my head
is when the Riddler First shows up and
he's like in the in the theatrical cut
he goes who the hell are you like really
big if you listen to it he started goes
and who are you like it's just it's a
very direct kind of you know you know
they also what I just remember too is
the guy in the safe yeah where he's like
oh my God it's
it's not in the cut at all yeah yeah
right you don't say [__] they just take
for granted that everyone's gonna
understand and you make this more like
cats yes oh my God it was crazy it was
like they did a test screening and one
person was like I didn't get it was that
acid no like we can fix that well same
like the guy in the alleyway like the
day glow like guy in the alleyway like
you know people my age we know that
guy's voice in that same like you know
burn you know but in this hey it's
Batman it's it's so interesting
the tone and Riddler's performance at
the end too in his big like glittery
outfit there it's the same shot but it's
they dubbed it to make it bigger to make
it more Jim Carrey and more more
definitely leaning more into the like
let's fun it up right which is why some
of the opening why you would
is more reorganization of the opening of
the movie there's definitely some
sequences that aren't there and of
course later on uh you know everyone
knows from the Batman Forever set of
cards that image of Bruce Wayne Facing
the Giant [__] bat that sequence is
in there there's a part of uh was it a
diary of his
parents his dad's diary that he blames
himself
for the death of his parents that's part
of his his trauma and stuff uh because
he wanted to go to the movies or
whatever to [__] and when by the time he
gets to the third act he he reads in the
diary that his dad wrote that like I
want to go see Zorro
and Bruce is like it wasn't me it was my
idiot father who got us all killed well
that's kind of different too because in
the movie you know when Two-Face and
Riddler raid uh Wayne Manor they shoot
him in the head and then and in the
theatrical head he wakes up and he's
like gotta suit up in my Sonar suit in
this one when he wakes up Alfred's like
the [__] Batcave has been destroyed
and Bruce like bat cave like what do you
talk he lost his memory in this version
and he has to like go into the cave and
go into his psyche and that's when he
faces the Man-Bat and he comes out and
he's like you know what I am Batman and
the man bat does look kind of cool oh my
God they spent a lot of money on it yeah
and it holds up when you see it like it
flaps its wings and he they do big
close-ups on it and it's they go around
him and Bruce very dramatically and
stuff but no expense no expense but you
could see why they took it out because
once again they're like we got to get
the kids back in this thing and he
replaced it with karate laundry which is
not in this that's not that's right this
cut does not have Robin going like
[__] laundry Foo you know Swift swift
this is how you drive this is how you
wash and so they were like we gotta take
the bat the giant scary bat out what
should we put in like kids love laundry
and they love karate kids love karate
what if we combine the two to show why
this boy should be Robin or something
I'm saying when I say boy I'm being
facetious that was the other thing in
watching this movie that I really forgot
like Chris O'Donnell is 86 years old
you know what I'm saying like part of
the poignancy of the Batman and Robin
relationship as Grant Morrison pointed
out years ago on uh Fat Man on Batman
when it went before we were fat man
beyond when it was just me one-on-one
interviewing him I made some crack about
[__] the Batman and Robin
relationship real low-hanging fruit
about like a guy and a kid and [__] and
he [__] manscaped you guys yes
he he got on me so [__] fast and not
he didn't shame me but he kind of did to
be like I'm not even gonna try to do his
accent but his whole point was like no
that's one of the most touching
relationships in comics and I was like
touching and he goes no [__] not like
that he goes like the the relationship
is this you have the boy who looks up to
the man that he wants to be and the man
who sees in the boy the childhood that
he was denied that's why their
relationship is so symbiotic and so deep
and beautiful
and in order for that to work it should
be a boy because there's no way a
grown-ass man like Chris O'Donnell like
you see him in this [__] movie he's
like two two [__] days younger than
Val Kilmer and [__]
well the man and they're like we need to
stick this orphan with you and it's like
why he's 28 years old I'm sure
he goes to leave on his motorcycle that
he rode to Wayne Manassas kids got a
license man he don't need no [__]
help well the one thing that the
Schumacher cut couldn't fix though is
like I just the whole third act when
they get to Ridler Island Robin first of
all is like useless he gets captured
twice he does do holy rusted metal
though yeah well that joke is in every
Incarnation I mean it's so good how
could it not be uh but uh but he gets
they they this cut doesn't fix that and
it also I will say in the theatrical cut
what this cut doesn't have is when he
reconfriends Riddler and he's like why
can't I kill you when he's all like
deformed on the floor that's not in the
in the Schumacher cut and that's one of
the best parts of the movie and I and I
I want like a perfect world where that
Scene goes back into this Incorporated
it yeah that's the one big criticism I
had of that cut the uh him the bad
morphing effect of him you know becoming
like the mutated Riddler and stuff I
mean you know that again I don't I can't
do any [__] in special effects but
like even I was like he says bummer and
you think that that's like a criticism
of the effect itself yeah I was really
into this and then the um but it's
would you say
that it's
a better version of Batman Forever yeah
absolutely I uh I I but I'm in that that
really insane minority where I actually
think that Batman and Robin is better
than Batman Forever oh my God if only I
know I know
well
Drake
[__] Mark needed to get a new drink
just for that comment sounds good he was
like give me another wakanda forever
I want to hear this why tell me because
I feel like that movie like Batman
Forever which very obviously now after
seeing this cut Joe Schumacher's like
here's the movie I wanted to make and
they were like we wanted to make a toy
movie so we're going to make your movie
into a toy movie now and then Batman and
Robin he went oh you just want to make
toys great I'll do that so I think that
that movie is a little more like
cohesive like that movie actually owns
what it is for minute one from the
beginning and it hasn't been cut into a
movie and Batman Forever is kind of
wishy-washy it's it's kind of wants to
be one thing but it's forced to be
something else you had him Joe you had
him for a while and then you lost him I
don't need them well well done
um I here's the thing man I a lot of
people like uh [__] uh why won't they
put this out I I don't know why any
Studio doesn't release as many versions
of a movie as possible if a director
wants to do so now did Joel Schumacher
go on record as saying like I wish they
would put this version out because Joel
Schumacher is gone so we can't find out
what his true wishes are no but you
could ask Akiva Goldman
who wrote the screenplay he wrote the
screenplay but that's not he's not the
director right now the director he might
have something to say about that maybe
but then again there's a studio that
makes cuts of things all the time
without a directors all I got to do is
Alan Smithy this [__] if they wanted to
I think that's kind of the problem is
that like it would be the Schumacher cut
and after the Snyder cut was so
successful I think that's why you know
it was kind of like hey the the people
have been talking about the Schumacher
cut but Snyder could still make the
Snyder cut Schumacher can't make the
Schumacher cut so it would if anything
it would just be an assembly cut and who
knows if that would have been like what
he you know ideally would have liked to
have and that's the only thing that I
would bump into is like maybe Joel
Schumacher was like Hey man the
theatrical cut is the cut and I don't
want anybody to see the [__] that we
took out some directors are like that I
I you know as a fan of this [__] and as
a fan of the cinema and filmmaking and
just being interested in the process I I
wish they would release it
um it's does the movie notion shame if
anything it [__] makes it it enhances
the experience of Batman Forever
um and you know on a purely greedy
corporate level they get another bite at
the Apple Man like there's they can make
some loot without putting a lot of loot
into it with Zack Snyder's Justice
League they had to put in 50 70 million
dollars to get it viewable you could
literally just put this out as an
addendum with Batman Forever and with
second disc that just has this cut on it
without spending another dime and
probably make some Loot on it in
physical media I mean Adam's the 30th
Anniversary like that feels like it's a
pretty good chance is it coming up two
years yeah two years so it's like you
know brand new 4k restoration of Batman
Forever plus Batman Forever extended
edition don't even have to call it
Schumacher cut we all know what it is
I'll say this version definitely fits in
more with Schumacher's filmography too
because like when you watch Like The
Lost Boys And when you watch flatliners
and falling down you could see why they
hired that guy to do Batman
and not like super dark but for
mainstream movies they have an edge to
it and it's Gothic and it has the
pageantry and it has and he was very hip
you know what I mean he started you know
it it this fits in with those movies you
know as it is now it's like he made
these really dope cool movies and then
he got Goofy for a while you know and
then made tiger land I don't you know
whatever he did I forgot deep Cuts yeah
wow they filmed that in my hometown it
was the first movie I ever saw being
filmed so we'll always have a place in
your heart that'll always have a place
back home
yeah but I showed it to my wife who had
never seen the uh original cut of Batman
Forever and like me and my buddy were
like freaking out at like everything and
she's like
I am sure like I'm glad you're having
fun right that's true I mean that's the
thing it's not like for everybody it's
not going to change cinnamon ship but
for
an audience that wants it and based on
what I've seen for the last few weeks on
the internet after we [__] talked
about it there's an army of [__]
people that really want to see it
there's an entire release the Schumacher
cut movement that was tweeting and
trending last week and I think they
might have trended today as well it was
in the LA Times they talked about it in
the LA times that you that you had this
cut of it so like I mean there were a
lot of news pieces like comicbook.com of
course and [__] like that I saw it go to
AV club and you normally a b Club is
always writing shitty things about me
and so this time they didn't they just
wrote an indifferent he has the cut kind
of thing
where's the the uppercut but they didn't
they didn't do that they were just like
he has the cut he says he's saying I see
some of the reports were like Kevin
Smith claims to have it
who would [__] make that claim
like what am I trying to get laid or
something like ladies guess what I have
I've also seen the thing where people
are saying it's like Warner Brothers is
working with you to like pretend like
it's a conspiracy thing and I'm a huge
Hollywood conspiracy theorist I think
it's all evil but like this but like
this is like no like it's just you
actually have those and I'll be honest
with you nobody has reached out for all
those articles you would imagine
somebody at Warner Brothers would be
like do you [__] have something that
belongs to us can we have it back and
they still let you into a Premiere okay
literally it wasn't an elaborate trap to
be like he's here yeah
I hadn't even thought of that [__]
because I did get invited to the
premiere rather late and it was after I
talked about the Snyder cup gosh I have
something over we got vegan cake right
over there yeah but really vegan cake
slam I'm like Joe Pesci like oh I'm not
get down I go why do I have socks with
those oranges in them I mean the reason
I shared it with you is because when I
first met you uh 10 years ago like three
days ago Facebook reminded me of I met
you three days ago 10 years ago and uh I
told you then that it was on like my
bucket list to see your original cut of
Jersey girl like that was you know and
then uh I was invited to an early uh
screening of Clerks three and can we
tell that story I mean if you want to
it's fine but so we have the Joe and I
we had an early screening of Clerks
three
um and it was the second one we did but
Lionsgate put it together and it was
pretty much curated we didn't like do an
open you know go up to the [__] mall
and ask strangers to go it was off of
like the off of the Kevin's that Kevin
Smith club or off of like uh the website
you know basically you had to kind of be
familiar with my stuff and be kind of
into it it they weren't getting
strangers cold to ask what they thought
about the third movie in a series that
they were not familiar with to begin
with so we have this screen it's about
100 people or something like that and
afterwards that everyone's applauding
and [__] and I get up to do like an
informal kind of uh q a slash focus
group and so I was like uh all right man
I'm in Lionsgate sitting in the back so
uh I go how many people like the movie
and and everyone's hands go up or
everybody applauds whatever [__] and I
was like well just you know for [__]
my own notification is there anyone that
didn't like it and [__] Joe's hand
went up and so and so I was like well
this we gotta [__] dive into this
and Joe gave a of a very
passionate
uh criticism of the movie he was like if
I remember correctly it was like you
betrayed your audience and yourself
[Applause]
still feel that way yeah
who was like our execut Lions get after
the screening
um she was like I was you know as soon
as you went up there to do your q a she
was like I was getting up to go home
because I'd seen you do the Q a before
and I heard the movie play so I knew
everything was fine she was like the
moment that boy started talking I sat
the [__] down
she was like I really wanted to know how
this was gonna go and they were like
mystified landscape people were like why
did you put up with that like why why
why would you let him do that and I was
like he [__] he was clearly he was a
fan like he loved clerks too and I love
clerks too so I I couldn't be like well
just because he didn't like clerks three
means that his opinion is validated you
know especially if like I share the same
feeling but I where we differ is I love
clerks too and I felt like clerks 3 was
an extension of Clerks too Joe did not
feel that way is there any way is there
any way I could tell you kind of like I
I sent you the email that you requested
did you ever get it I
it was 13 Pages oh my God
yeah uh secret he never changes if you
want to see it I turned it into an
hour-long video essay that I released
about it did you yeah yeah because like
it but again out of completely out of
love and I mean that right right and I
just want to say the toughest love there
is Joe 13 Pages well you're I mean
you're an artist reaching to millions of
people man like you're you know you're a
God to us you know what I mean you
really are well but so a God that must
be killed
myself
is there any way I could just share with
you a like a fan fiction version of how
what I would have done at the end I'll
take it I'll say look I'm a Kevin Smith
fan I want to hear it so Dante Dante
yelling at Randall right Randall has the
second heart attack yes and in this in
my mind so Randall has a second heart
attack he's you know and Dante refuses
to go to the hospital because he [__]
hates Randall at this point and Elias
gives him [__] about it and puts him in
his place kind of like the reverse of
what happens Dante has to go and figure
out how to edit this movie and in
editing the movie he realizes oh my God
this is Randall's love letter to me and
my friendship and this is him trying to
get me back into the world he goes into
the hospital he shows Randall the movie
and Randall dies and he tells me I you
love me I you know you see the world in
your own way and thank you for bringing
me back Randall dies he has the funeral
then Dante just enters it into some
festivals or something the movie
actually becomes a big hit and you end
the movie with a kid coming into the
quick stop looking round and asking hey
I'm sorry but is is this where Randall
Graves shot inconvenience and Dante then
shares with him the story of his friend
whose perspective inspired that kid to
make movies because that's what you
really did that's that's what you did in
real life and I think that that's why I
think that's why clerks three like hit
me the way it did because I felt like
you're killing off that side of you like
that you've spoken about and I mean
we're all here because of both sides of
you working in Tandem and to kill off
the one that like cared for people was
weird for me and it still hits me in
that way but like but it's my
perspective yeah was that the side that
didn't care for people aged into caring
for people I get that the guy who I've
been trying to kill for [__] 30 years
I finally got to kill because remember I
wanted to kill him in the very first
movie and [__] and it was a bad idea
laughs but but you're right it was a bad
idea I didn't mean to be rude I love you
to death
it was a bad idea so much so that we we
cut it but for me that felt like like
the closure I I like I got nothing but
respect for the notion of like I I in
fact like the idea of a scene where
somebody comes in and is like hey man is
this where they made that [__] that's
flowery Jersey Girl era [__] a little
bit which I loved by but I but I am I
know
but after we showed the Snyder cut Joe's
take on it was he which I thought was
cool he was like you were right to cut
all this [__] he's like your commercial
instincts made more sense like the
version that you released to the world
of Jersey girl is better than this
longer cut you attempted a James L
Brooks and you landed on a great John
Hughes that's how that's how I feel and
I wanted to say you said beforehand you
talked about uh you and gilmosh
um who I met one time at ArcLight and he
said how do you recognize me I said from
The Jersey Girls documentary and he was
like oh God
no here's a true story he said to me he
said do you want a picture with me I
said sure and he took he took my phone
and he framed a shot of us Sigmund he
died like a week later so taking a
selfie with you like after he died a
week all I know that could be the last
we've just had you in the show for 20
minutes that that could be the last
frame that vielmost ever shot but uh
that's you talked about how he was you
know you wanted to do close-ups and he
was like I lit all these wide shots and
I lit you know and you said I love my
dialogue I want the close-ups
don't disagree but there's a shot in
this version it's not in a theatrical
cut of Ben Affleck on an elevator when
he's going up to the uh yeah you said
that that shot communicates thematically
and emotionally
everything that you've done to that
point not only in the movie but in your
career and it's it's one of your finest
moments and you know what I noted it's a
wide shot with no dialogue it is true
you're better than you're better than
you give yourself credit for no I'm not
yes you are yes you absolutely are no
the night that you have the day that you
had your heart attack the day that you
had your heart attack on the uh silent
but deadly you ended that by saying I'm
not talented and that and I could not
disagree more we are here because of
your talent because of your vision you
are the best and I mean thank you
give it up for Joe everybody
fam
Batman is back yes so I shoot you not
maybe two weeks ago I deleted the video
I shot of your q a from that Clerk's
thing because I was like there is no way
that dude will ever get in the room with
Kevin Smith again
so I deleted it off the computer and
like I have faith that like peace in the
Middle East can happen because you guys
were able to reconcile nobody outside of
I think Shannon was in that room except
here tonight you guys were you guys was
that not the most uncomfortable room
you've ever been in in your life
this is this is incredible I did I
treated him with respect though I was
not like yeah no it was just weird to
see somebody
in a room full of 300 150 people just be
like that [__] sucks
did it I don't know I'm used to that
kind of thing uh wow this is usually the
numbers are flipped it's like one person
likes it and everyone shits on it that
was the one day where I was like oh my
God I think I got everybody and Joe was
like hold my beer I was anyway I'm I'm
impressed yeah where do you go
this is uh Joe said he's written and
directed 15 feature films because of him
he gave me credit but you did it and
this is what is it called
Natasha Hall and it's available on
Amazon and it stars Joe's wife
I will totally watch
I'll totally watch this because I trust
you now there was a part of me when you
gave me a thumb drive that I'm like I'm
gonna stick this in my computer it's
gonna be child porn and the government's
gonna show up and that's his revenge for
clerks three
but once I saw that it was Batman
Forever I'll Trust anything you put in
my hands now
[Applause]
thank you it was amazing um all right to
sum up on on the Schumacher cut uh
Warner Brothers should absolutely put it
out a lot of people have been asking me
online like you should distribute it and
apparently they don't understand
legalities
copyrights and [__] like that but I will
say this
uh I cannot uh [__] I got a movie
theater but I can't like sell tickets to
something that I don't own uh however my
movie theater I live at so it's
technically also my house
so
um we're doing uh what is it
I'll give you two bites at the Apple
July 1st we're doing uh clerks cartoon
Marathon it is uh it's called bear is
driving the clerk's cartoon Marathon
Brian o'holland is going to be there
Jeff Anderson is going to be there we're
showing all six episodes of the clerks
cartoon which is more than ABC did they
showed two and canceled it and [__]
um if you're there for that and there's
like we've sold uh I think we're at 170
tickets so there's like 50 tickets left
to sell it out if you're there once
we're done at midnight
maybe we'll watch a movie
for free I ain't charging so if you're
there you stay afterwards we'll watch a
movie here's the second bite at the
Apple on August 25th we're gonna do fat
man Beyond at smog Castle Cinemas we did
it in March we're going to do it again
in August August 25th tickets have been
on sale for a while now I think we're at
about 140 tickets right now once our
show is done
if you stick around
we're going to watch something else I'm
not going to say what it is but it's
probably the Schumacher cut of Batman
Forever
not charging for it so I don't want to
hear [__] from Warner Brothers and stuff
but for the people that are really
interested because there are [__]
Legion of people online who are like
release it please put it up online and I
that's ridiculous I'd get sued the pants
off of but if I showed it on my [__]
laptop or my version of a laptop is a
[__] Barco projection system in a 230
seat theater as long as I don't sell
tickets I believe I can do it I'm sure I
might hear differently from a lawyer
somewhere down the line but there it is
you go to either of those two shows
stick around afterwards we'll all watch
it together
you have a higher resolution version
we'll watch a better [__] version of
it
that's true all right yeah man [__]
get me that done and done uh so there it
is if you're at home and you're like I
want to see the Schumacher cut it's two
play two ways for you to see it that's
my castle Cinemas we're not charging you
for it it's a free screen and uh but you
got to be there for the other [__] and
whatnot so make of that what you will
now there's going to be a host of
Articles tomorrow being like Kevin Smith
gets sued by Warner Brothers
and will never be allowed to see the
flash sequel
what flash sequel indeed
um all right we're done with the
Schumacher cut
hey
let's move on to other things give it up
for Joe man we I wouldn't have had that
without Joe
uh do we have news to dive into we have
a handful uh before we dive into news
speaking of Spa Castle Cinemas uh I will
be there in two weeks next week I won't
be at Spa Castle Cinemas or here I'm
going to Michigan for astronomicon uh me
and a bunch of you it's almost like a
viewsk universe takeover of astronomic
on I was supposed to be there a few
months ago but weather froze the Detroit
airport and so we couldn't go so they're
making it up uh in uh next weekend and
it's me and Jason Muse and Brian
o'holler Jeff Anderson Jason Lee uh I
think Ethan Supply's gone Harley's going
to be there this is the first time my
wife Jennifer is going to a con as well
uh Austin who played blockchain Trevor
who plays Elias so if you're in the
Michigan area in Livonia particularly uh
it's Saturday and Sunday then the
following weekend we have a big signing
at Jane Silent Bob's secret stash uh for
these two books so you know I do comic
books right
secret stash press did a book called
masquerade and we did a book called
quick stops this is the hardcover that
comes out in like two weeks I guess you
could order it wherever you order your
comic books we'll be selling them signed
at the stash these are the [__]
nicest things anyone has ever made of my
comic books [__] hardcover no slip
cover on top of it just [__] dope
Dark Horse makes a really nice book so
we're having a signing at the secret
stash can't get tickets anymore it's all
sold out for Saturday and Sunday where
we sign masquerade and quick stops
hardcover then as I mentioned before at
night at smog Castle Cinemas on July 1st
we're doing the Bears driving Marathon
the clerk's cartoon marathon and then
afterwards we're gonna watch a movie
that I don't own
um the very next night we're doing The
Blues Brothers that's July 2nd then this
is almost sold out July 29th we're
celebrating my birthday my brother is
August 2nd I'm gonna turn 53 but it's on
a Wednesday nobody goes to the [__]
movies on a Wednesday so July 29th the
weekend before we're doing a birthday
event that is uh us reading the Superman
live script in front of a live audience
the longest version of the Superman live
script and I'm working on getting
somebody cool to read it with us and
stuff no it's not going to be Nick Cage
a lot of people are like get in a cage
I'm like if I could get Nick Cage for
anything it would be Tusk 2 you know
like I'm not gonna I'm not gonna blow it
for [__] a Superman script reading
um but uh that is July 29th and I think
there's 10 tickets left to that all
these tickets are available at
smartcastcinemas.com then as we
mentioned before August 25th Mark
returns to the east coast and we do fat
man beyond uh live from smod Castle uh
Banff man will be holding down the fort
out here and streaming in as he did last
time we had a good time then the next
night we're doing a um uh Marquetta made
a joke last time we did the show about
uh we should do a Tim Curry film
festival called keep calm and Curry on
and uh we are not doing a whole festival
but we are doing a double feature so
August 26th uh for one price you come to
spawn castle and you could watch clue
and then me and Marco get up and do a q
a for a movie we had nothing to do with
it and then the second movie is Legend
Ridley Scott's Legend where Tim Curry
plays the devil so that's the [__] that
I got to sell also uh I'm coming to
Knoxville Tennessee for Fanboy that's
the following that's a July 8th or 9th I
believe it is and then I'm also going to
Shreveport Louisiana for geekedcon and
that's in August so there sometimes we
don't sell manscaped or Bluetooth
sometimes we say yes can you believe it
sometimes we sell a little bit of Kevin
Smith so that's all the ways you can see
me if you're not here or if you're not
in New Jersey now
uh Mark Bernardin here used to be a news
man kids and uh you know since the
[__] writer strike he's not been
allowed to [__] ply his trade as a
writer so he's gone back to being a good
news man uh and he's got all the news
here give it up for Mark Bernard and
he's got some [__] news
[Applause]
uh all right I have I have two stories
left uh both are about Marvel Comics ooh
one of them is uh is interesting the
other one is sad which would you like to
do first uh interesting first
interesting
um there's a new Stan Lee documentary
that dropped on it's on Disney plus
Disney Plus
well I'm fancy as [__] so Disney Blues
um and it turns out that some previous
collaborators with Stan have issue with
the amount of ownership he takes over
all of the Creations that came out of
Marvel during the time took took well
sadly Stan takes nothing anymore he
takes nothing anymore but this
documentary does position things in a
certain way
um and so Neil Kirby who is Jack Kirby's
son asked his daughter Jillian to post a
statement in response to the Stanley
documentary that recently dropped here
are a couple of pertinent excerpts from
said statement let me guess he's very
happy he's thrilled to pieces
I understand that as a documentary about
Stan Lee most of the narrative is in his
voice literally and figuratively it's
not any big secret that there has always
been controversy over the parts that
were played in the creation and success
of Marvel's characters Stanley had the
fortunate circumstance to have access to
the corporate megaphone and media and he
used these to create his own Mythos as
to the creation of the Marvel character
Pantheon he made himself the voice of
Marvel
so for several decades he was the only
man standing and blessed with a long
life The Last Man Standing his father
Jack Kirby died in 1994. if you were to
look at a list and timeline of Marvel's
characters from 1960 through 1966 the
period in which the vast majority of
Marvel's major characters were created
during Lee's tenure you will see Lee's
name as co-creator on every character
with the exception of Silver Surfer
solely created by my father
are we to assume Lee had a hand in
creating every Marvel character are we
to assume that it was never the other
co-creator that walked into Lee's office
and said Stan I have a great idea for a
character according to Lee was always
his idea Lee spends a fair amount of
time talking about how and why he
created a Fantastic Four with only one
fleeting reference to my father indeed
most Comics historians recognize that my
father based the Fantastic Four on a
1957 comic he created for DC challenges
of the unknown even naming Ben Grimm
after his father Benjamin and Sue storm
after my older sister Susan
I was very fortunate my father worked at
home in his Long Island basement Studio
we referred to as the dungeon usually 14
to 16 hours a day seven days a week most
of the artists writers anchors Etc
worked at home not in the Marvel offices
as as depicted in the program
through middle and high school I was
able to stand on my father's left
shoulder peer through a cloud of cigar
smoke I witnessed the Marvel Universe
being created I am by no means a comic
historian but there are few if any that
have personally seen or experienced what
I have I know the truth with first-hand
knowledge
my father retired from comic books in
the early 1980s and of course passed
away in 1994. Lee had over 35 years of
uncontested publicity much naturally
with the backing and blessing of Marvel
as he boosted the Marvel Brand as a side
effect of boosting himself the Decades
of lease cell promotion culminated with
its County appearance in over 35 Marvel
films starting with X-Men in 2000 thus
cementing his status as the creator of
all things Marvel to an otherwise
unknowing movie audience of millions
unfamiliar with the true history of
Marvel Comics my father's First Credit
didn't appear until the closing crawl at
the end of the film adaptation of Iron
Man in 2008 after Stanley Don Heck and
Larry Lieber the battle for Creator's
rights has been around since the first
inscribed Babylonian tablet it's way
past time to at least get this one
chapter of literary art history right
enough said
wow
uh thought
I mean I am also not a Comics historian
um but the the Legends we've all heard
of Stan as the greatest salesman in the
world of especially Stanley yeah
um do not seem to contradict that
accounting of things
um time also has a way of
recasting the lies one tells themselves
is truth and so
I am not to say one way or another who
did what to whom who did what right or
and what wrong but I think it is clear
that the parentage of the Marvel
universe is not as clear-cut as we've
all been led to believe
um a lot of people have always said this
is I didn't invent this quote other
smarter people said it first but the
greatest creation of Stan Lee was Stan
Lee himself and uh one thing is for sure
uh
whether or not he is truly the
co-creator of all these Marvel
characters
um he's certainly
knew how to sell those characters and he
knew how to sell himself in the process
and when he was doing this
Comics weren't a multi-billion Dollar
business they were an art form they
weren't even considered an art form if
really at that point it was disposable
cheap entertainment for children
so you know I don't think the dude had
some sort of Insidious master plan to
steal credit from people I think he knew
how to sell and went out there and sold
and you know is it easier to sell by
being like uh I came up with this [__]
it's not like he said I and I alone came
up but that the guy never claimed to be
an artist right and it depends on what
you think where creation begins you know
what I'm saying like uh
Michelangelo
did David the sculpture of David right
but somebody said hey you should do a
sculpture of David
and we'll give you money he was like oh
all right so
did the person who commissioned the
statue of David truly
come up with the Statue who's the
creator in that instance
um you know it's
it's a slippery [__] slope I
I talk about my work and I've never been
like you know I created Jay and Silent
Bob purely from my imagination I created
Silent Bob from my imagination Jay is
based on Jason news as has proven out
like over the years and as I've said in
front of him behind his back all the
time instead
um I never take the a film by credit for
that reason because it tends to leave
out everybody else in the process it's a
little misleading I'm not saying others
shouldn't do it but for me I'm never
comfortable because it takes a village
to make a movie and stuff uh when Stan
was out selling Comics tub thumping for
Comics back in the 60s and 70s I think
he was just trying to do it as you know
efficiently as possible and the subtle
nuances of like well I I created these
characters with artists and what happens
is sometimes an artist comes into your
office and they have an idea and then
you tell them to go Josh and then I was
the one who dialogued it and came up
with all the backstory but it's a very
long explanation when it's just easier
to say like I created or at least in my
lifetime I never heard him say he
created as much as he said he co-created
and if people gave him credit he
generally again in my lifetime while I
was around quickly corrected them to say
like well it was me and Steve ditko it
was me and Jack Kirby now that was
probably after years of pre-internet of
this other creators being like Jesus
where's all the credit I'm getting or I
should be getting from my contributions
to these characters which you know
probably became a bigger issue once
these characters took on the longevity
that they would then show a lot of
people
back in the early days of comics didn't
want to even cop to the fact that they
worked in comics because they were
trying to work in other fields and
Comics was just a side hustle and
whatnot in a world where these
characters lived on and became part of
the pop cultural landscape and a new
American mythology and then later on you
know profitable billion dollar [__]
characters uh naturally of course you
want to make sure that everyone who was
involved has their due and gets the
credit their their uh they're due I I
don't think Stan Lee was a villain maybe
I just want to believe that about a guy
who I met late in his life who perhaps
learned from his mistakes in the past
about not crediting everybody as clearly
as he could have and stuff
um but all I know is the guy I knew from
1995 on was very quick to give out
credit to all the people that he worked
with
um and that's I think all I could say
about that I mean I also think that that
part of the issue that that Neil Kirby
has is that the documentary specifically
is a very one-sided documentary it's
documentary about Stan it's a document
about Stan and it's not it's not Comics
history it's just the story of Stan Lee
right and so the perspective of that
story is coming from Stan
um clips that they use to tell the
narrative are all stance Clips right and
so to him that gives you a somewhat
skewed perspective on what the truth was
right and what is a documentary's
relationship too and responsibility
for the truth
um which I don't have an answer for I
didn't make that movie as a journalist
you try and Endeavor to get as close to
what happened as possible but
documentary is still
even based on fact based on a true story
is never a true story yeah you know like
documentary key word here is story right
you know there's always some element of
fiction even in a documentary how you
choose to order things changes in
audiences perception on those things
um so I think that's that's his big beef
specifically with this documentary at
this time which seemed to pull off an
old wound that led him to to recant the
tales of his perspective on the creation
of the Marvel Universe
um I guess we all get a chance to watch
that documentary ourselves it's on
Disney Plus on Disney Plus
bamf Banff man is here I'll I'll also
say this like as somebody who's done a
lot of video editing
um and as somebody who's put out short
films who's done interviews who's had
I've had my words edited I've gotten
into issues with friends where it was
like I wrote this I said like I wrote
this short film with XYZ
and then in the printed article on
Nerdist it's like
writer of this short film JC rifenberg
and they come after me and I was like
well that's not what's on her tape
recorder
but they don't know what I said and now
I'm a villain and I'm not saying that
Stan Lee always credited everybody all
the time but the video gets edited to
match The Narrative of the filmmaker
making it the interviews he's done for
what 50 60 years get there's 500 Words
that can go into a thing and he talked
for
you know half an hour and they have to
cut it down and hit a
space in the margin and a lot of that
stuff can get left behind and then
people get shitty with you
when you were like well I I said
co-creator with this person and then
that just Falls away because it's not
part of the story the journalist wants
to tell there was a just today I had a
mini version of this where there was an
article I did an interview with rolling
stone about uh Nick Cage Superman and
Spider-Man and The Flash and and you
know it was
more it wasn't like uh this is earnest
news you know I was [__] being pithy
and making jokes and [__] like that and
so uh the journalist uh brought up like
uh some people online are pissed about
the cameos in Flash in the third act the
George Reeves of it all the Christopher
Reeve the uh Adam West so forth and I
said yeah I didn't bump into that I so
I'm and again I'm not quoting myself
exactly but essentially I was saying
like I saw that as homage that didn't
bother me in the least I saw it as
homage and then I pivoted right to the
joke where I was just like look like
most actors get in this to be seen and
to live forever you know relevancy like
and most actors I know and or I think I
might have said I don't know a single
actor which is essentially the same
version of most actors I know who would
not want to be remembered after they
were [__] dead and I was like look as
far as I'm concerned you could [__] I
hope to God somebody puts me in [__]
after I'm dead I've been spending my
last 30 years trying to [__] keep my
face in the public eye and be relevant
so you can stick my dead ass in porn
after I'm [__] gone
and so you know again this wasn't an
Earnest [__] like 60 Minutes
interview or something like that it was
a pithy Rolling Stone article and
somebody was just like uh kind of came
at me about
um George Reeves and brought up like
George Reeves suicide and uh you know is
is that
Cameo of George Reeve Superman
respectful to a man who took his own
life because he couldn't get any roles
after Superman and
they were kind of taking the position
that I was like you know every actor
should be used in perpetuity whether
they want to or not whatever the [__]
and you know I simply do put like four
[__] tweets and I put after I said
look I agree with your second tweet my
take on it is the same like you can't
use an actor unless somebody signs off
on it either they act to themselves or
their estate so we're kind of on the
same page why are you coming at me and
then the dude took his tweet down
because he was like oh I didn't read the
article and I'm like what the [__] man
exactly read the headline and came at me
and [__] like that so it's I'm not
saying this is all a game a telephone
and I don't think we're sitting here
trying to be Stanley apologists as much
as my heart would like to be a Stanley
apologist because I liked him quite a
bit
but
he wasn't the only person telling his
story and in the instance of this
documentary he's not even here to
[__] tell his story anymore
um you know I like JC said you could say
a bunch of things to a [__]
journalist and they're going to print
what works for them and you know if you
sit I've sat there and gone out of my
way to over explain [__] anybody who's
been at a [__] q a of mine or even
watched this show like knows that I
could put a lot of [__] words
together and be as clear as [__] day
and then the next day online somebody
will take [__] one thing I said and
turn it into a [__] article that
represents nothing of what I truly said
so I'm not saying Stan's a victim here
not by any stretch of the imagination as
I began with Stan was an incredible
salesman and I respect all the work he
did in selling comic books as a viable
art form for all those years before the
rest of the general public caught up
and I also respect his ability to sell
himself in the process in the process of
selling himself did it sell others short
perhaps
I don't think that was in his intention
but if he did like I said in the years
that I knew him he always seemed to try
to make up for that he was always the
first to correct even me in conversation
where I talk about like well this is
Spider-Man's baby daddy and he would be
like not just me Steve ditko and you
know so forth and so on so I it's I get
where the letter comes from uh at
particularly pointed piece as a kid
talking about I saw the birth of the
Marvel Universe through a haze of
[__] cigar smoke and there is no
secret that like Jack Kirby just like
Jerry Siegel and Joe Schuster like so
many like Steve ditko so many comic
creators
got [__] you know not necessarily by
Stan Lee but by the corporations that
owned their work there was a recent
thread going through Twitter last week
Comics broke me and it's from a bunch of
people who work in the field artists who
are getting incredibly underpaid to draw
comic book pages and ink them and color
them and [__]
um and how people have put into a lot of
work into the field and you know it's
it's taken more from them than than
they've gotten from it and it was
predicated on the death of a of an
artist anybody know the artist's name
I'm sorry I didn't Deep dive enough I
should have come prepared but he was
young and uh in his 30s or something and
I he passed away I'm not sure quite how
but his death prompted this this uh
hashtag that went on for almost a full
week Comics broke me and a lot of people
kept bringing up Jack Kirby because Jack
Kirby apparently has a very famous quote
where he said to somebody in an
interview or he said to somebody who's
coming up through Marvel Comics will
break your heart kid as they seemingly
broke his you're talking about a master
of the not just comic book art form but
of graphic arts in general and arguably
uh Jack Kirby created such Dynamic work
that it forced people to look at comic
books differently uh in his lifetime and
I remember a long time ago being a Stan
Lee kid like back and this is like 1995
that was doing press on Mallrats Stanley
he was in Mall Rats and you know I've
made the mistake of saying something
like you know Jack Kirby I never
understood Jack Kirby's art and I
remember Alex Ross
like said publicly in an article he's
like I'll explain it to you Kev because
he knew how important Jack Kirby was as
an artist I've always been a word Smith
I love comic books but the first thing I
look at oddly enough is not the pictures
is the word balloons and stuff so I was
always more inclined toward the writing
than the visual aspect of it which I'm
sure is going to get me chewed a new
[__] on the internet but I've since
learned and I've since grown that's the
beauty of [__] being alive and you
know Staying Alive is that it gives you
the chance every day is a [__] school
day and you could correct mistakes as
you go forward and become more educated
and stuff so I for my money I don't
think Stan was ever trying to rob
anybody of credit in the process though
people have been robbed of credit not
just by Stan they've been flat out
robbed by the corporations that own
these characters as well you know what
what's that
Bill finger look how long it took
[__] Bill Finger to get credit for
his work and that wasn't him versus Big
Bad Warner Brothers that was him versus
[__] Bob Kane Bob Kane the creator of
Batman went out of his way to deny Bill
Finger credit for decades all throughout
his life until both of them were gone
and then suddenly Warner Brothers in DC
were like well
maybe we got to include Bill Finger on
this and now it's shitty Batman thing
going forward says you should just say
Batman created by Bob Kane now it says
Batman created by Bob Kane with Bill
Finger I believe so you know as
Comics become more prominent and they've
never been more prominent than they have
been in the last 10 20 years with movie
technology special effects technology
catching up to the point where you can
depict the imaginations of some of the
most creative [__] Artisans that ever
walk the planet and [__]
uh Credit Now more credit is being
extended because more people are finding
out about
the everyone the village that it took to
create a lot of these characters
um so I guess that's all we could see it
reminds me a little bit of uh like who
created the iPhone Steve Jobs did he no
yo who who who created Apple Computers
Steve Jobs well what about Wozniak right
that's kind of like the Crux of
uh the whole Steve Jobs movie and the
his you talking about one of the world's
greatest salesmen you know the dude I
mean look guy's got a Salesman line
where he's like put a dent in the
universe that is such a [__] salesman
line right there I'm not saying like he
did nothing but like it takes a village
and
that guy was just the front man
um and able to speak about it eloquently
and uh was there for every [__]
interview and was there to drive with
passion and but ultimately a Salesman
so um
vibey woodchuck in chat says I don't
think Stan was stealing but people
definitely got robbed agreed 100 man
that's eloquently it took me 20 minutes
to say that
who said that uh woodchuck baby
woodchuck well Ivy woodchuck a vibey
vibey woodchuck well done Bobby
woodchuck
there's a future for you as a Salesman
someplace
um all right that was story that's not
the sad story that is not the sad story
I don't know that really brought the
room down well let's see how low we can
go
um
the great John romita Senior oh that is
a sad the last of the great Silver age
creators uh passed away at the age of 93
announced by his son John meter Jr also
an amazing artist also an amazing artist
I say this with a heavy art my father
passed away peacefully in his sleep he
wrote he's a legend of the art world and
it would be my honor to follow in his
footsteps please keep your thoughts and
condolences here out of respect for my
family he was the greatest man I ever
met
um John romita Senior co-created uh
characters including Wolverine The
Punisher and Mary Jane Watson among many
many that very famous image when you
turn the page of Mary Jane Watson saying
face it tiger you hit the jackpot as
John ramita Senior yeah amongst many
other things yeah a legend 93 man 93.
that's awesome to go that far the only
you know you only wish that could just
go on forever somebody
who adds that much to the culture
shouldn't have to die ever but we all
got to go 93 is a [__] fantastic run
and what an absolute Legend a name that
defines comic book greatness and and
again his son [__] also an equally
great powerful [__] comic book artist
j-r-jo jrjr one of the greatest [__]
Daredevil artists on the planet
um yeah you're right that is sad man but
like what's not sad is everything that
John Ramirez senior gave us while he was
alive particularly when he was drawing
comic books created a lot of joy
created a lot of characters that are
still viable today still working today
and will never die you get a piece you
get to taste a little bit of immortality
uh if you work in in these businesses
man like the business of show and all
sorts of forms and whatnot I think
that's what drives a lot of us man it's
like to do something that outlasts us
knowing that one day we're going to
leave this best of all possible worlds
and you know for a lot of people of
course having children is the Legacy is
the way to be like I was here and then
there are those of us who that's not
enough we want to make something leave
it behind and let people know we were
here John ramita Senior absolutely did
that what a legend uh let's give it up
for the great job for me to see me
[Applause]
uh all right we're done with the news
indeed as the news giving up for Mark
you gave me the [__] news
foreign
that only leaves one part left to the
show the auctioning of all these things
that I signed
this is quite the [__] deal I was
sitting here thinking about it man if
you go to like a comic book show to see
me like I was just a Dallas Fan Expo
they charged like [__] 80 bucks for
me to sign a thing all you have to do is
buy a ticket to this show and you can
get anything you want [__] signed
we don't even do this at smodcast Castle
you should believe me I'm sitting here
trying to figure out how to make money
off this [__] right now I'm like it's a
lot of money sitting on that bar
oh my God speaking of a lot of [__]
money man when we did a screening the
first screening on Thursday night of the
flash uh Keith who lives in Jersey
um he's a big comic book art collector
and I saw him at Dallas Fan Expo every
time I see him at one of the cons he has
some glorious piece of [__] comic
book artwork that like is is rare and
precious and [__] so he referenced being
like a jersey boy I was like you live in
Jersey he's like yeah I've told you that
before and I was like well come see the
flash on Thursday and bring your artwork
so he had what he'd show me the Dallas
Fan Expo is the first cover of The Flash
that debuted kid Flash's costume
um I'm sorry I can't tell you who
[__] drew it or whatnot uh somebody's
smarter than I could and I was standing
next to guy when he described it but I
didn't retain
but it's signed by Carmine Infantino
it's signed by Julie Schwartz like a
host of [__] DC Legend son I think
maybe it was a Carmen Carmine Infantino
cover
um he had that he had a couple covers
for All-Star Comics that dated back to
the 40s and he had Todd McFarland's
Batman 4 23 I think it is with the
gigantic [__] Cape like classic piece
of uh Batman art that like you know Todd
McFarlane of course worked on Batman
Year too but that cover
is it's iconic it's just that the Cape
is its own [__] character on the
cover he's a woman in his arms and [__]
he's got the dark the white slits For
Eyes stunning [__] piece of artwork
so Keith got up on stage and he was
showing off these pieces and telling
like where he got them and how he came
across them and you know he's not one of
these guys that does it for the money he
does it because like this was my
childhood and these stories mean
something to me and blah blah blah but
you know while we had a crowd there I
was like yeah that's all well and good
but how much does this [__] go for
and he was so reticent to say
um and I know why because he had to get
out to his car after the show
and on that stage that night we had no
less than like four to six million
dollars worth of comic book artwork that
McFarland cover alone is a seven-figure
piece of [__] artwork and what was
crazy was he bought it from Gareb
Sheamus who ran wizard for years and so
garib there was a on the back of the
piece he showed me the price that garib
paid for it what he bought it for from
either McFarland or somebody who got
sold it to got it from McFarland and
sold that Gareb Sheamus now wizard was
late 80s early into the you know all
throughout the 90s and into the Arts
um so take this with a grain of salt
in terms of what was what what they what
garib must have paid for it back in the
day
for this cover that is a seven figure
[__] cover right now Mo like not just
like one million dollars couple million
[__] dollar cover man
eight hundred and fifty dollars it was
sold for talk about a [__] markup man
like that seems Sinister though because
why Sinister wizard was the price guy so
he bought it for 8.50 and then next
month printed it's worth a million bucks
[Laughter]
I don't think he ever had it as worth a
million in any wizard man I think that's
its current market value and stuff but
man
you know sooner or later you let a piece
go when you let it go and who knows what
he sold it to Keith for Keith wasn't
really forthcoming about what he bought
it for and stuff but I'm sure Garrett
made you know money on the deal but
could you imagine like and Keith's not
going to sell it he has no interest in
selling this stuff he collects it he
doesn't get into the you know the kind
of money aspect of it all he thinks
that's kind of gross he's like somebody
got to save this these pieces and keep
it fun he's like there was a time when
this was just fun it was a time when
nobody knew what this [__] was worth and
just preserving it was what it was all
about but he goes it's become a very
costly [__] Hobby and [__] uh it was
interesting though
Heist yeah yeah [__] yeah man some
better writer than us should come up
with a storyline about that very thing
all right so is it time for Q a yeah we
got we got cues we got cues and we got
some A's man and we got gifts for those
that uh come up here and uh have their
their questions chosen what do we got
Mark well we got this uh gift bag it
seems to be an Indiana Jones dialogue
Destiny theme gift bag from uh Brett
deakin and the good Folks at 40x oh our
good friend Brett deakin this is if
you've never seen a movie in 40x the
[__] is your problem
uh it's it's like going on a ride to see
a movie man it'll keep you awake and
[__] so these bags come with free 40x
tickets this motherfucker's leather look
at this a leather or at least pleather
Indiana Jones leather-esque sleeveless
vest
you know like he wears in the movie
uh 240x tickets uh a sleeveless Indiana
Jones and the dial of Destiny vest
what's in the box Fox
uh Moscow Mule like uh copper cup
is that right yeah so it's a cup let's
take it out and look at it whip it out
each of the bags are different oh they
are you're right this one has
a Indiana Jones the dial of Destiny
hardcover book oh yeah it is a copper
cup and this looks like a journal
um
and it also has
a canvas bag that says Indiana Jones and
the dial of Destiny so yeah you're gonna
get some [__] man if your question gets
picked and it's good enough and let's be
honest it's always good enough I don't
think we've ever been like your
questions sucked nope sit down oh but
this is it's a different kid this ain't
a canvas bag this is like a gym bag and
[__]
so you're right JC each bag each gift a
40x gift bag comes with different gifts
in it plus
two tickets two tickets two tickets per
so you get to go see oh and there's
something different than this what the
[__] is that open that up find out what
that is
are you shopping or I am I'm gonna pick
through this [__] [__] all you people I
need I got me a new gym bag
it's like a journal slash passport
holder let me see I got a passport
could maybe have use I need a passport
that needs holding oh it is a [__]
passport holder
and and you can put money in it too
and it's uh it's made of snakeskin no
I'm kidding
um that's nice all right so the good
Folks at 4dx have come through again man
is is Brett here is Deacon here he was
too busy with work to come always
[__] working 40x man we'll give it
he's not here but raise one up for Brett
Deacon ladies and gentlemen
all right here come our three questions
all right question number one Kevin
Conroy a Kevin Conroy not the Kevin
Conroy that's the Kevin come right now
give it up for Kevin Gom Roy
thank you thank you
all right
so my question is Indiana Jones related
it is uh what quest uh or item of Legend
would you have Indiana Jones search for
oh
that's [__] good man well certainly
not the dial of Destiny
I'd never heard about that until this
movie
um Ark of the Covenant captured my
imagination as a kid because I was
Catholic and we had that like they
talked about it in the Bible and [__]
and I was like oh that's real
it is
I'm very gullible and naive I'll buy
anything comment you know I love comic
books but that's because I love the
Bible before that
it's a series of [__] superhero
stories they just don't wear cool
costumes
um
let me see the second one was uh the
shankara stones
I mean you know in DC Comics like
they're always going after the Spear of
Destiny so longinus yeah it's the it's
the spirit that pierces Christ on the
cross when the Centurion is like let's
see if he's dead and he pokes Jesus with
the Spear of Destiny and so the Spear of
Destiny figured prominently on a lot of
DC stories
um I would like to see him go after the
Spear of Destiny well look I would like
to see him retire
this poor guy retired like [__] two
movies ago rode off into the sunset and
they're like nope not done yet
uh but in a world where it was going to
happen again I would say the Spear of
Destiny man I thought it was always cool
when they crossed him over with
religious iconography uh you know and
that just Harkens back to the first one
as well so having him go after the Ark
of the Covenant uh and then having him
go after uh a spear of destiny that'd be
pretty hot in my book that's what I'd
have him go after either that or the
Declaration of Independence
so he could run into Nick Cage man we
get a twofer on that one and [__]
what about you mark uh I think I'm gonna
cross a little universes it's still a
religious artifact
but I would like to see him go after the
hammer of Thor oh [__] molineer molnir
and would he be worthy of course he
would well that's the question at the
end of that movie is is he worthy
um because it is a religious artifact
yeah just not the sort of Judea
Christian faith yeah
um it may or may not actually exist but
it's super [__] cool yeah and if you
can pick up that hammer you become
[__] Thor
so Indiana Thor Jones oh my God through
Indiana Jones wait a second so Disney
owns Indiana Jones and Disney owns Thor
they can make that [__] movie only do
that [__] get Harrison Ford on the phone
one more time one more time okay
I'm sure he'd be like how much all right
polish my Champs kalista we're going
back to work
uh that's tight I would like to see that
excellent job uh great question give it
up for Kevin Conroy
do you want the cup
[Applause]
well done man smart chat was all about
Excalibur
oh [__] man I
think yeah so we showed Excalibur and
that's that would have been a good one
[__] yeah uh questions
yes the charm of making
uh question number two Joe Pasquale
what do you know Joe
what do you got first Joe
hello hello hey Kevin before I I say
anything today being Juneteenth a
special day but it's also uh my 13-year
wedding anniversary of my lovely wife
congratulations say your name because
that'll get you laid tonight
[Applause]
thank you Chloe I love you you're
wonderful where'd you go where'd you go
Everyone likes a good story where'd you
guys meet how'd you get together uh
we had both just broken up and I walked
into a coffee house and I sat next to
her and we talked for three hours we
talked about [__] the stupid issue we
talked about growing pains and the show
Growing Pains and how Kirk Cameron for
some reason I can't [__] see that
show anywhere and uh just random [__]
for three hours like it was effortless
and I had never had that with anybody
else and you just both come out of
relationships yeah we I bet you everyone
in your lives are like oh it's just a
rebound yeah I had to get out of my
place I was just crying and sad and not
eating and I had to just get the [__]
out and I went to this coffee house and
I sat down and there she was and 13
years later look at that yeah I'm giving
up for 13 years well done
today Juneteenth got me that's the day
outstanding uh so my question is in that
horrible Flash movie
laughs
you started so sweetly with your wife
and
now you're like here's my chance to [__]
on it
uh so uh Flash's Antics to change the
past affect the castings of Back to the
Future footloose and Top Gun if you
could go back in time and change the
casting of an iconic film in pop culture
what character would you recast and why
oh wow what a great question deep cuts
um all right let me think
I would put Michael Keaton Batman in
literally everything
even if it wasn't a [__] superhero
movie and [__] like you know [__] The
Greatest Story Ever Told he could be
Jesus
because you'd know that he'd get off
that [__] cross
[Applause]
all right I would I would like to have
seen the Ghostbusters that had Eddie
Murphy as Winston zettel
foreign
that was a thing like that was a thing
and I think he bounced to do I mean he
was the original conversation was all
[__] SNL guys and so they wanted
[__] Eddie to be that role he then
went into Beverly Hills Cop and then
couldn't go and do Ghostbusters the role
kind of ebbed and flowed and came and
left the movie for a while finally came
back and then Ernie Hudson got to play
it but the version of that with Eddie
Murphy is Winston zetamore
um as a as a as a pop Relic I would kind
of love to see that as a pop Relic and
because it's uh uh pertinent to our
Indiana Jones gift bag the Tom Selleck
Raiders of the Lost are
[Applause]
uh or the do gray Scott X-Men with him
as Wolverine that's the guy originally
cast as Wolverine and then something
pulled them out of it wasn't an injury
right it was
mission impossible to could you imagine
losing Wolverine forever because if not
mission impossible mission impossible
too
um I would like to see uh that as well
uh anybody else have any versions
Carter Victor Garber as my best friend
yes cast him as my buddy who
was he ever close Alec Baldwin is Batman
I mean I like I I always felt like of
anybody in Beetlejuice you would have
[__] picked him because he kind of
looked like a Bruce Wayne and [__] but
no regrets man because Michael Keaton
was the [__] Choice
um anybody else have any
who Emily Blunt is Black Widow is that a
thing
that's right yes
Bill Murray in the Tom mankowitz Batman
script that he wrote Tom mankowitz was a
script doctor that wrote most of what we
know dick Donner's Superman uh movie to
be like Mario Puzo wrote the first draft
Tom mankiewicz did most of the [__]
work and created that the movie that
dick down or then went forward on he did
an interview in starlog years ago with
the Return of the Jedi on the cover and
he talked about a Batman movie that he
had written that they were working on
and he was the first person I'd ever
seen talk about a dark knight version of
Batman taking the character back to his
more Grim Origins taking it away from
camp and there was an illustration in
the star log a cartoon uh of Batman
wearing a [__] what looks like the
current day Batman suit and this article
of starlog came out in 83 six years
before Batman would ever hit the screens
and he was wearing like a [__] more a
mean version of the bat suit and [__]
and he was slamming a door on the Adam
West and Burt Ward versions of Batman
and Robin and he was going pay no
attention to those two or something like
that so he talked about in that article
Bill Murray as as Batman Peter O'Toole
as Alfred the Joker
like the sad clown version of the
character oh uh and then somebody fairly
recently said that there was and I don't
know it's not me leaning into what you
just said but
Bill Murray was was intended to be
Batman and in what iteration Eddie
Murphy was going to be Robin
but it was a serious take on the subject
or at least more serious than the campy
version and stuff so excellent [__]
call I would that'd be kind of hot to
see Bill Murray Batman
excellent question yes well give it up
for Joe
the cops were the best the cup one
I mean Chloe might like that vest yeah
it comes to the vest
yes
dude happy anniversary take it over
there
Joe is gonna wear that vest to bed
tonight and nothing else
as he
[__] Dives in for that dial of
Destiny
wasn't there a Bill Murray or wasn't
John Belushi supposed to play
Ghostbusters in Ghostbusters
I think that'd be interesting excellent
not better but interesting yeah also the
other one that nobody wants to see was
Stuart Townsend as Aragorn in The Lord
of the Rings movies
he was uh the lead in The Lord of the
Rings the lead non-hobby was going to be
Stuart Townsend who was cast played the
lead uh Vigo Mortensen oh that was Vigo
and who is Stewart Townsend he was
he was going to leave Extraordinary
Gentlemen I think he was he was in
League of Extraordinary Gentlemen I
think he Dorian Gray right I'm not uh I
don't go big on the Lord of the Rings so
I
but good to know
thanks cheers
uh and then last what happened was he
cast and he was he was Eric Stoltz he
was cast
and they started probably pre-production
costume tests and they were like oh
listen this isn't it and I think Vigo
was put on a plane and flown to New
Zealand and was acting the next day holy
[__] I think is the
the legend too bad it didn't work out
he was in all those movies right yeah
uh last question Aaron Anderson from
Canada Aaron get on up here everyone
give it up Burns you're gonna take us
home
[Applause]
what part of Canada
I'm from Kitchener Ontario Kitchener
I've [__] been there yes you have I
did I saw the Kids in the Hall there
[__] back in 1995. so I'm doing Live
come and seen you in Toronto multiple
times as well so thank you very excited
my first time meeting see
oh my God he's got his own [__]
Canadian following and [__]
oh we love Batman hey
um I regret my question so much right
now you regret it yeah
we're talking The Flash we're talking
Batman iterations yeah a traditional
question would be Mary [__] Hill
I'm regretting the option it doesn't
feel like a very Canadian question man
I know who are we gonna marry who are we
gonna [__]
are you ready to kill who are three
choices all right so I I feel like I
know who's gonna be a top for you which
is Michael Keaton yeah
well by me which one is that
well that's definitely not killed but is
it Merry or [__] it's just for your Brea
that's just for your consideration all
right okay our second is you know an
actor that could play the shark and Jaws
Ben Affleck Ben Affleck yes I love him
and then my third was George Clooney but
I want to add an extra option to this
question so very [__] kill and Jeff's
kiss and we're gonna add Christian Bale
into the mix so we have Mary [__] killed
Jeff's kiss Michael Keaton Ben Affleck
George Clooney and Christian Bale this
is a real [__] Sophie's choice right
here I know
I like all those guys for one thing or
another all right so
Mary
I go Ben Affleck
yeah
one of my favorite people on the planet
and I don't get me wrong I think he's
very sexy there's a [__] shot that
Jennifer put up for holy [__] man did
you see that picture what the [__] that
dude's like 50 years old he looks like
he looks incredible being married to her
has put him in somehow in better [__]
shape
I saw that picture it was a [__]
thirst trap and I was caught
[Applause]
he looked so [__] good so I I he's
100 sexy and [__] like that but I mean
sex Burns a lot of calories that's true
and he also looked tired
it was just like these [__] abs
snap
um I would uh as much as as sexy as I uh
he is
um I would I want to I want to grow old
with him
you know what I'm saying he's a funny
[__] dude man and like you know he
can make me laugh and he's also smart
and very charming and and just a good
guy he's got a real good heart and stuff
and um you know I uh of course I always
when you think of people you think about
your the era that you spent the most
time with him and like I spent the most
time with him like from I would say Mall
Rats up through you know uh Jay and
Silent Bob stroke back and over those
years I got to see him go from like the
dude who slept on my couch
to like the dude who sold me his house
at a very reasonable price and uh and I
got to live in it for the last like 22
years so
when I think of Ben I think about that
version of Ben and uh he's never changed
whenever I saw him at the air Premiere
he was at the flash Premiere but I
didn't see him until they did the intros
in the beginning Andy machete was like
Ben Affleck I was like he's [__] here
I was like Dustin Hoffman of The
Graduate he was like
[Applause]
um so I would marry that [__]
man because I would grow old with him
man uh [__]
I guess that leaves Michael Keaton
but you know what yeah that stands to
reason because I so [__] with that bad
version of [__] Batman and and I
wouldn't want to grow old with Michael
Keaton here's my Michael Keaton story so
Michael Keaton goes to the Dogma
Premiere and I'm a huge [__] you know
fan of Batman as well as the rest of his
work and [__] so he's uh we have the
premiere at the harmony gold screening
room here in Los Angeles and uh he's
there and I see him going in on the red
carpet and [__] it's about halfway
through the movie
you know I've seen Dogma zillion times
at that point it was a huge cigarette
smoker in those days and US 90s kids
were like [__] unrepentant art and
cigarette smokers like I would go to
events that didn't allow smoking just so
I could light up and be like I'm a
smoker I was that [__] and [__] so I
leave my Premiere in the middle to go
outside and have a [__] cigarette and
who is outside on his cell phone but
Michael Keaton having like a full volume
conversation with an agent about his his
[__] job or whatever so he's left my
movie to go have a conversation outside
so I'm sitting there having a cigarette
and just watching them [__] talk and
he pays no attention to me this whole
time he's talking and then finally he
looks up and sees me and I'm the guy who
got up to introduce the movie so even if
he didn't know who I was at that point
he would know who I was and so Michael
Keaton's on the phone he's like no I
don't want to do that and he sees me he
goes yeah but great movie man yeah but
[__]
oh
um so I would [__] Michael Keaton Batman
um let's just kiss it first
see I got nothing against the other guy
but like Clooney just seems like an all
right [__] dude man
like Clooney
Clooney my one interaction with Clooney
goes back to when he made
what was that
there he is
in case you don't know what George
Clooney looks like
for a second I was like he's here like
the door open I was like what the [__]
well he does have that booze right
Giuseppe how are you come on in what is
the is the what was the movie he
directed about to Chuck Barris the uh
yeah Confessions of a dangerous mind
so that was that the first thing he
directed that was the first thing he
directed so I'm at the because it's so
name dropping so Hollywood but this is
how it happened I was at the Chateau
Marmont for something and I was waiting
for my car for valet to bring around my
car and we had a website called movie
poop shoot that was based on the movie
poop shoot from Jane sound Bob uh strike
back but you know it became a legitimate
[__] website that had people working
for it that reviewed movies and [__]
like that and I guess whoever reviewed
uh Confessions of a dangerous mind
didn't give it a very good review
so I didn't review it somebody working
for that website did and I guess all
George Clooney got out of all that was
Kevin Smith's website [__] on your movie
so George Clooney comes over he goes I
hear you didn't like my movie and I was
like what God no that's not [__]
confessions I thought I thought it was
amazing he's going your website didn't I
was like oh I don't run the website I
was just I just own it and stuff and he
goes yeah
[Laughter]
uh so I was like oh my God this is
horrifying for me there there's the real
George Clooney
so then George Clooney I don't know if
he saw the terror in my face or whatever
but he went to make me more comfortable
and [__] he goes that's all right he's
going like let me tell you a thing that
me and my friends just did he told me a
[__] story that I was like so Charmed
by so I guess Kenny Turan who used to
review movies for the LA Times I don't
know if he still does he doesn't he
doesn't so he used to back then and I
guess I killed Kenneth Terrain
yeah
no when I was at the times he was
retired he was already gone he Kenny
Turan wrote the review of Mallrats which
I still quote to this day
um he had loved clerks and he did not
like Mall Rats at all a lot of people
did not a lot of the critics hated
ballets and his review opened the
Mallrats review in the LA Times said if
Sundance or the AFI ever wants to offer
a course on what not to do as a second
feature Mall Rats should be at the heart
of the curriculum that is [__]
verbatim if you look it up online right
now word for word I'll never forget that
[__] man I don't remember my wedding
vows and I remember the [__] opening
words of [__] Kenny turan's review so
I was delighted by this story when
George Clooney shared he goes well Kenny
Taran didn't like Confessions of a
dangerous mind either he's gone so me
and my friends we went to his house and
we egged at that
I was like the [__] and he goes that's
not even the best part of the story he's
going then I did an interview where
nobody asked me the question but I said
the hell I did I did not egg Kenny
turan's house
and he and I said why'd you do that he
goes because then Kenny tranwood knew
that I [__] egged his house
is that Andrew give it up for Andrew man
that was a quick [__] fine well done
[Applause]
Andrew the unsung hero of fat man beyond
always hiding in the back but making
magic and [__] uh okay so he gets the
Jeff's kiss because what a great sense
of humor and then by process of
elimination that leaves Christian Bale
to
I mean I wouldn't say kill but
that is the question you kind of have to
say kill like back off Canada [__]
but yes I guess ultimately then I would
kill him but not because I'm like [__]
Christian Bale just because those other
three guys are pretty damn awesome I
mean could we before I go Aaron yes
we're friends now
um when I think of that approach
could we could we broaden the sample
selection like could we add more Batman
yes absolutely
look what happened oh sure I didn't want
anybody here yeah excellent that means
you get Adam West you get Kevin Conroy I
know Val Kilmer uh either Kevin Conroy
not this Kevin Conroy I'm going to marry
George Clooney
because he's rich cause he's rich [__]
smart good play I hadn't thought of that
I mean I was marrying for love you're
marrying for money so much smarter he's
got that [__] house in Lake Como he's
got the [__] tequila brand like we're
set yeah
um I'm a I'm a I'm a I'm a [__] I'm a
[__] Val Kilmer
[Applause]
because that's a beautiful [__]
man absolutely
look at those [__] lips that's it's
all lip all lip what can you do with
that much lip whatever I want him to do
with that much lip
excellent call it's gonna be a sloppy
Gotham party bottom
plus he's probably a real genius in bed
yeah
thank you ladies and he knows how to
keep a top secret oh [__] oh still going
I'm Jeff's kissing Kevin Conroy yes give
it up for the late great Kevin Conroy
deserves every Jeff's kiss in the world
[Applause]
um and I'm I'm gonna kill uh Robert
Pattinson oh
[Applause]
you didn't even an option and you
brought him out
see Belle likes it Belle knows
um why because he's sparkly vampire
Sparkle that
um just because he's so [__] morose
all the time anyway like
I don't know
I don't know it I'm not gonna say
anything just he's a dude who doesn't
he's in love with life so I'ma just help
[__] hey man Genius answer you
deserve the [__] bag well done but
Aaron asked the question ever gets it
back give it up for Aaron
thank you
wow man this [__] good round of q a
and [__] hell yes that brings our show
to a close kid did you have a good time
this evening
I cannot thank you all enough uh for
coming out remember man if you uh love
the The Flash keep on loving it if you
didn't like the Flash come sit by me
yeah
laughs
um give it up for uh the guy who this
year's bar it belongs to and stuff we
don't get to do the show live in front
of people or not for him or not for scum
and villainy cantina located on
Hollywood Boulevard in Hollywood
California if you've never been here
make it a point to get here and then ask
for Banff man himself JC give it up for
JC
thank you
uh don't forget kids if you want to
maybe if you wanted to see a movie for
free at smog Castle
that some people are deeply invested in
seeing go to smartcastcinemas.com right
now get yourself some tickets for the
Bears driving clerks cartoon Marathon or
the fat man beyond live show August 25th
out there in [__] New Jersey uh you
know who's going to be standing next to
me or sitting next to me at that show
because oddly enough that's modcastle we
sit yeah this is a long time and get my
steps in at this [__] I've been
on the picket line in a while so I feel
good being yeah how goes the strike
I'm still not working so it's going
great
um the uh give it up for the dude who'll
be sitting next to me in Jersey on
August 25th tickets at smogugusta
cinemas.com or the dude who's generally
always standing next to me right here at
the scum and villainy cantina uh the
level-headed pragmatic [__] honest
one of the two of us kids
give it up for the great Mark Bernard
and that is fat man beyond for this week
I'm Kevin Smith I'm Mark Bernardi tune
in next time same fat Time same fat
Channel smodcast.com or youtube.com
Kevin Smith Jeff's kiss
[Applause]
this is the cat greetings everybody and
welcome to the AKA ask Kevin every Saga
has a 10-year anniversary ladies and
gentlemen and this is what happens with
Jay and Silent Bob get old up Kevin
Smith
[Music]